No,
the Joe Rogan experience
all day,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
International Man of leisure and
the first ever the youngest ever UFC
heavyweight champion,
Josh Barnett,
ladies,
gentlemen,
I highly stressed.
They can't take that.
They can't take that from,
you know what I'm laying
on top of it right now.
Bag of Oreos and,
and my feet propped up on a,
and a lovely lady.
Unless some Mike Tyson type
character comes around.
When did at 20,
you got that shit locked up.
Don't really see that happening.
So weird,
isn't it?
The heavyweight division is weird.
Well,
ever since a lot of that
drug testing came into play,
you're not going to see an 18 year old
roll up into the UFC at over 200 and some
odd pounds and to start
laying into people.
Isn't it possible though,
like one of those freak athletes that
would normally make it into the NFL?
It'd be He's got a dad that had been a
martial arts instructor his whole life,
that kind of thing.
Sure.
I could see it.
But then again,
the poll is,
uh,
if you could make it into the NFL,
you're almost,
you're okay,
I'm going to take all that
money now and play in the NFL.
And then if I feel like being a fighter,
I'll do that.
Right.
Like Hershel Walker did,
like,
like Hershel Walker did.
Although,
I mean he is a freak of freak of freaks.
I mean,
when you look at Herschel,
he shouldn't be in the kind
of shape he is at his age.
Yeah.
And he says he eats like a bowl of soup
and a salad every day and a snickers bar
or something.
Yeah.
He's got some weird thing
going on too though.
He has multiple personality
disorder that's trauma induced.
Maybe one of those personalities eats
while the other one doesn't know about it.
The other one's working out all the time.
And so you're getting all your caloric
needs from one guy and the other guys
doing all the working out
the other dude jerky off.
Uh,
then,
then you have the one dude that does
your taxes could be useful thing.
It would definitely be
useful thing for your mind.
You compartmentalize like that,
you could really pretend you don't jerk
off and really pretend that you don't
eat and you just have a bowl cell in
the soup and you're fucking superman.
I barely even have words.
Wow.
You got fucking white powder all over
your hands and chalk from Olympic lifting,
calluses,
calluses from man.
I don't know what you're talking about,
man.
Threatening me.
That's Mike.
A bunch of engine blocks
out in the front yard.
I'll overturned Mike lives
this part of my brain.
Mark did it.
Yeah,
he was unbelievable.
He was like 48 or 49 his last fight in
strike force and he just looks like a
fucking Greek God.
Yeah.
That's the kind of guy that I don't
even think science could make be that.
Well,
and you know what I mean?
Like there are guys out there that like a,
I have a buddy Mike O'hearn,
right?
He's 40,
I don't know,
46 something like that.
And he's a family friend
from way back in the day.
He's from uh,
Juanita or Redmond,
Washington originally.
He's friends with my,
my brother in law.
He,
everybody,
we all know
him,
know him for a long time,
ridiculous shape.
He can get up to monitor,
don't to 85 still fairly lean,
pull 700 pounds off the floor.
He a hundred pounds.
It's ridiculous amount of strength.
Then he can go ahead and shred down to
two 44 something because there have two
42 to do some photo shoot.
Mr Olympia a little,
I'm here,
I'm here for this uh,
Supplement company or that supplement
company or guests thing here and still in
training do,
I dunno,
600 for reps to squatting and
you're just looking at it and go on.
You know,
his whole thing is being a natural
bodybuilder his whole life and he's,
but it's,
I wouldn't,
you couldn't,
there's nothing you could say they
could ever diminish his what he's done
because no,
it,
it's just like there's
nobody else out there.
I don't care what you shoved in them
and what you didn't shove in them.
You can't be that guy.
Right.
He's just that sick,
strong.
And he still looks like
he's like 30 so you're just,
yeah.
Won The genetic lottery unless you
have some sort of crazy radical genetic
engineering down the pipe,
which probably is going to happen,
whether it be lifetime maybe.
But yeah,
like there's some dudes,
no matter how much steroids they take,
they're just,
you're never going to compete with
some ridiculous freak athlete.
Now,
Mike is one of the most genetically
gifted and a hardworking,
of course to people I have ever seen.
He also has a world record for
running through plate glass windows.
I know that.
I felt like,
yeah,
no shit.
He does right that race.
But I know you win football gear and a
helmet and they line up these plate glass
windows and this huge long line,
this light like a,
a two two line or three line deal,
Domino's.
No,
no,
no.
Each one is individually set up
and he smashes through the first,
the second.
And you need to keeps going,
you know,
and sometimes you run into them,
it bounces you back and you
just gotta keep driving.
Oh my God.
He's also got a black belt in judo.
Jesus Christ on the American gladiators.
He,
uh,
he was on battle dome,
Battle Dome,
a kind of remember that?
Yeah,
it was battle dome again.
Think lower rent,
American gladiators.
It was meaner and people got hurt more.
That's running.
Everybody had a very
obnoxious or ostentatious,
like very gregarious character,
very over the top.
And so he was Mike Odell,
like the perfect Greek God,
although come on,
that's not very Greek.
But uh,
but then,
uh,
you know who also it was on,
there was a,
God,
I can't remember his name.
He played in the NFL.
He's incredibly funny.
Uh,
Terry crews.
Terry crews is on battle dome.
Was He really?
Yeah,
he was,
I don't remember.
And then there was another guy,
Eric Paulson used to train them and
Eric even did the psycho Guy Gimmick,
the Hannibal Lecter deal.
And they had an event on there where
you'd have to get a guy off this platform
over the lines.
And Eric used to just murder
everybody in that event.
And then one of our guys who fights,
who is one of our CSW dudes,
he actually went on to
battle dome at one point,
uh,
j Martinez way back in the day and
he wrecked all the dudes that he saw.
Aunt who got,
he got onto the platform
that get the push out.
One,
he just fucked him all
up and they were so,
they hated him so bad because there was
like another event where it was football
ask,
you know,
Terry Cruz and Mike would just practically
take people's heads completely off
their body.
It was,
it was really bad.
I'm surprised.
And when they redid that,
they redid a,
not this one,
but the other one.
Gladiators.
Why didn't that take off?
It seems like that would take off.
They'd haul Kogan Laila Ali.
Gina Carano was one of the ass kickers.
What channel was that though
during the writers strike?
Was it during the writer's strike?
That's what it was.
But it's still a reality show.
Like those that seems like it
would be an easy one to do.
Like they,
you know that a wipe
out is kind of similar.
But no one kicks your ass.
Right.
And now people love that
American Ninja Warrior.
Yeah.
That's,
I don't know.
I don't know why I didn't
actually continue as well.
I figured,
well,
you know it has a little bit of distance
in it and two seasons and that shit was
it
done?
Well,
whenever you have like
people that you have hired,
like you hire a Josh Barnett and you,
you have to smash some
dude who's competing.
It gets kind of weird.
It's like it's not,
not really,
you're not competing
against another person.
You competing against a
hired guy who's does not.
So the,
if the guy gets hurt,
if someone gets hurt
and like you heard them,
like I could be pretty easy to sue
the company that makes that show.
Like you're an employee.
If you,
if you know some dude makes it run at
you and you fucking clothesline him and
he's paralyzed,
he have a waivers man.
They fight those things
and when you fight them,
if a,
if a lawsuit is strong enough,
it's got enough power behind it,
enough legal power behind it.
I wonder if that was it or probably not.
It's probably just writing.
So I think it was just ratings.
I think it was just ratings.
It's interesting when you think about
what guys are capable of like physically
with the maximizing
your genetic potential.
Like there's certain,
there's a certain level that you can't
get past and it's one of the reasons like
when everyone talks about like steroids
and performance enhancing drugs and
what's what's fair and what's not fair.
The hundred one thing
that's 100% not fair.
His nature.
That's true.
It not fair at all.
She's a bitch [inaudible] murder,
you will
drown,
you will set you on fire and
we'll also just let you show up.
You know,
the,
the proverbial gene pool has
been pissed and you know,
get born with stubby fingers or you know,
half a leg like down syndrome like well
good luck because you how that works.
Yeah.
And if you're an athlete,
no matter what you do,
like there's certain guys you just,
you know,
the Hershel Walker's to certain types
of dudes that just are always going to
have that advantage.
What
you do.
Herschel was a fan.
He was a really well versed,
uh,
you know,
he had a good career in the NFL,
but he never was the guy
more than anyone else.
I mean,
he had all,
he,
he had some years where he,
and you always knew he was solid,
but he never was the top dude.
Really.
I didn't know that.
No,
he was never the number one guy.
And often towards,
later on in his career,
he was usually the backup guy or the
dude who got brought in for all the,
all purpose yardage or a well,
because Herschel could run
and catch and possibly,
I bet you if you throw the ball to him,
he could,
you know,
he could throw a pass down field.
Right.
He could probably play defense event.
It's just right.
And then they would do those NFL
a off season competition things.
Right.
Or they take all these different players,
uh,
on NBC or something and they would all
compete against each other and little
events,
uh,
throwing the football through through
hoops and through tires and a sumo in the
beach,
sand,
all this different stuff.
Right of the network stars
like that kind of thing.
But just for NFL players,
the NFL would do it and Herschel
Walker won every single one of them.
He was delay every time,
but he was not the best running back
in the NFL during his entire career.
He was not the best fullback he would,
but he could play full back
running back quarterback.
He didn't get fucked up either.
It's like Bo Jackson's out there
crushing everybody eating yards up.
Boom.
His hip goes out right.
Or a Steve it and taking uh,
interceptions and running them back 90
some yards as a defensive tackle or dnd
and boom,
his need gets blown out.
You know,
stuff like that.
Not Herschel Walker,
he doesn't get hurt.
Yeah.
Was Weird,
right?
Yeah.
He's,
he's a specimen,
but he never was,
like I said,
he was never the number one guy.
Right.
Did you see that thing
recently about Jeremy Horn?
Jeremy Horn said zero injuries
are 117 fights or something.
That's insane.
I have no idea.
He must be made out of fucking
flubber rubber maid or whatever.
You know,
he just bounces back out.
Yeah.
They call them gumby.
That's always been his nickname.
Right.
You know,
he just says it just focuses
only on technique and he's
never been a strong guy.
Well,
he,
he's got a point and it's
something that I've stressed a lot,
uh,
when we talk about fighting and that
is so many guys have learned how to be
stronger and faster with or without
drugs and learn how to defend certain
positions and,
and,
and hit hard,
but they don't have a full
well rounded skill set.
They've all got these plan A's and no
plan and their plan B sucks and their
plants c isn't even a thing.
And then when they slowed down a step,
they lose a little bit.
They come up across the guy who's either
stronger and faster or just a little
better striker or too,
too good of a,
too good at something that
will just derail their plan a,
they start losing when they start losing,
they just nosedive.
They lose four or five,
it's five fights.
These guys that would go out
there and mop these dudes up.
Boom,
boom,
turns a corner.
They can't sustain a career
because they have no technique.
They do not have the finesse,
the uh,
the touch,
the feel.
They don't own it.
They never developed it.
They just became really strong,
really fast.
Hit Hard,
overwhelmed out athlete,
their opponent.
What'd you call a front runner?
A yes.
For the most part.
And Watch,
you know,
you,
you watch these fights and how you all,
man,
this fight's going to be so good.
And then it's whoever's gets out first.
Oh that guy wins whoever's game.
Whoever's plan a starts
first wins a fight.
It's interesting when you look at MMA too,
it's so few guys or what
you would call durable.
You know,
it's,
it's very difficult to like,
like when you see like Steve Bay meo
chick versus a junior dos Santos.
Sure.
If one of those crazy
fucking five round wars,
there's so few guys that can
engage in those kinds of wars and,
and,
and make it out of there.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's true.
And honestly,
especially as a heavyweight,
uh,
with all that power and strength,
you go through that,
what's your next fight going to be like
and your next one and the next one and
how many of those you really
want to get involved in?
Yeah.
Like when you see a guy like Jr and you
see those wars that he had with Cain and
you know,
you knowing your,
I mean you've had a long career man.
You knowing like the toll that a
fight like that takes on your body.
Do you see him diminished at all?
Do you see him slowed down?
He's
a step.
He's a step slower.
Junior is a step slower.
He's not quite as durable.
He doesn't react the same way
to getting hit as he used to.
Uh,
you know,
know and,
and here's the thing,
someone might get on
Twitter after this and go,
oh,
Josh Barnett,
it says that you're not as
good as you used to be junior.
I was like,
no,
that's not an insult.
I'm it.
What it's saying is that you're the,
what do you have been through what you
have done through to yourself and trading
and what your body is and isn't willing
to accept or isn't willing to or is able
to do.
Just buying the natural string of how
things went in terms of your career to
this point.
This is what it is.
Take what you have now and adapt it.
It's in the end.
It's really only it's up to you to to
decide whether or not what you're going to
do is going to be successful.
If you could only,
if you,
you're so set in your mind that it can
only be done one way then when that way
is no longer,
what is best for you to do as an athlete.
Prepare to have the
shit kicked out of you.
Now,
if you're willing to adapt,
reapply the things that you've already
done well at some new things in.
Just do them a little differently.
Make small changes.
Well then now you can go ahead and you
can have 19 years of career instead of
seven,
six,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
That doesn't make,
that doesn't.
If you could run out there and double leg
everybody in the beginning but now you
can't do that anymore.
But instead you were able
to set your double leg up.
Just makes people react,
hit him on the way up or hit him and
then get a body lock and finish that way.
How has that any fucking worse
than what you were doing before?
Just because you didn't do it how you
used to but you're still getting to where
you want to be.
To me that's still success.
It's an interesting situation where you
see there's some guys that still have
like a single minded pursuit,
single minded skillset,
like they just want to wrestle and box.
That's it.
They never throw leg kicks.
They never,
and those guys are going to get their
fucking shit pushed in once they come over
that,
that magic every line.
You don't know when that's going to be,
but it's going to happen and then
they're going to fucking nosedive.
There are going to be washed up has beens.
So it seems like in this
day and age especially,
you kinda like,
okay,
like it's certain divisions,
like there's certain divisions like
say if you want to fight flyway,
you better be able to do everything.
You know,
mighty mouse is just so God damn good.
You don't have to fight that guy.
You better be able to do everything.
And he's a rarity.
Most guys are not going to be him.
Right.
And I've,
I've known DJ since he was just this
kid up at the gym who is too small to
really get any fights in a way
class that he really belongs in.
And uh,
he trained diligently over,
even when he knew he
wasn't going to get fights,
he was in the gym day after day
training and training and training,
training,
hard training,
easy training,
fast training,
slow training,
and doing what Matt had told
him that he needed to do.
And that's why he is the way he is now.
Uh,
when I trained under Matt,
I did the same thing.
I trained constantly.
I trained when Matt wasn't around,
when it was my own free time.
I spent that going over what we,
what was working,
what wasn't working,
why was this working,
why wasn't this working?
How can I make these better,
uh,
shadowboxing,
figuring things out,
altering and,
and the things that Matt would say,
well,
I need you to do this.
Ah,
I don't really understand why or
what can you explain it to me?
Well,
because I need you to do
this so that you can do this.
Create,
elicit this reaction,
whatever.
Well,
I still don't get it,
but I know what you want,
where this is supposed to lead to.
I'll figure it out.
I will play with it and play with it
and play with it and play with it.
Not talking about my cock,
but in addition to that,
I will keep playing with it
until it makes sense to me.
And then I can come back and now I can
ask a question that has purpose to it and
instead of just,
I don't get it.
Of course you don't get it.
You're not going to get it.
Lots of things.
You're just not going to get the first
time until you live in it until you wrap
it,
wrap it around you like
a skin and understand it.
Uh,
and then you might even
make a decision to go,
what you want me to accomplish with this.
It isn't that effective
for me to do it this way,
but if I just make a little change
to it because of the way I'm built,
because of my own natural tendencies,
what have you,
I can get that.
I can get what you want and,
and do it,
do what you want and till the
weekend end of that end point,
we can get there.
And,
but you can't understand that until
you've taken the time to make that thing
yours to fully understand it.
And there's some things,
you know,
something take techniques of Matt that
he's shown me over the years that I can
teach others I can't pull off or the shit,
it's just not my move.
I'm not really built for it.
He was built for it in May.
He made it work better.
And the same was with Paulson,
you know,
just sitting there and,
and taking all this information in and
understanding and pulses backgrounds even
more varied than that.
So he'll come at me and go,
okay,
Hey,
do this.
I'm like,
that's really from left field.
Okay,
but there's a reason I'll figure it out.
I'll figure that out.
Is that one of the more frustrating
things about being an MMA fighter when you
tried to talk to people
that don't know fighting is,
there's so much complexity and so much
technique involved and the person on the
outside,
it seems to be like a brute sport
involving strength and weight.
[inaudible] and it does
involve those things.
Uh,
but it's,
what's that?
Aliens.
But it's not take,
oh,
true.
We've had alarm issues
in this fucking building.
I heard,
I saw him.
I'll try and get in.
I had to fight my way through the front
to the front that you made it through,
dude.
Nah.
You know,
a lot of people don't understand how many
different techniques are involved are,
and how much,
how many variables are
involved in training.
I can't be too angry at the
ignorance of the casual fan.
It's not their job to be that first the
fan that that does go that extra mile
and learn about the history,
learn about why this technique would
work and who these people are and where
they come from and what
this is and what that is.
That's awesome and amazing
and I really appreciate that.
I don't begrudge the person that doesn't,
I don't like it when
they say really ignorant,
mean spirited stuff.
You know what I mean?
When there,
but that's a different thing altogether.
That's somebody trying to,
yeah,
be a dick on purpose to try and cut
somebody else down that that's a whole
different animal,
but just not understanding.
It's okay.
I personally,
when I get into something,
I do want to fully understand it,
but that's just the kind of person that
I don't even mean people that are into
it.
I mean the casual person
that is not aware of them.
A,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing
that so many people,
yeah,
that person
is,
you know what it could be anything.
And fighting is,
while it is something that is available
and exists within every human being,
right.
Ability to fight,
everybody has the ability to fight.
Never Seen Brian fight.
Obviously.
I didn't say fight.
Well he doesn't even have the ability.
He just starts falling down.
Yeah.
I just tried to kiss you or something.
Just make it really awkward.
Awkward.
So you just want to leave it open so
you don't want to punch his tongue.
Hold on.
Just hold on to your belt loops and just,
uh,
off here offers shoes up to you.
You would look really good.
And what's been the biggest
change over your career?
I mean,
cause you,
you've been around for,
you know,
I think the first time I saw you
fight was 96 or 97 something.
Something along those lines.
What,
what,
what year was super broad when
you fighting Superbowl 99.
99.
That's when it was,
yeah,
99 was the tournament.
Uh,
2000 was Dan Severn and then
2001 was my first UFC fight.
So what was your first MMA fight?
The first ever MMA fight?
Uh,
my first ever MMA fight was probably,
it was 1997 of January.
I was on winter vacation from
the University of Montana
and I got a call from an
old wrestling coach,
uh,
if I,
cause he knew I was trading,
he knew I was into it and at the time he
was actually doing Matt Hume's website.
And so he goes,
hey,
would you be interested in fighting?
Uh,
sure.
All right.
Woo.
Uh,
Chris Char Nos.
Oh,
that guy's fun.
Super Ball,
right?
Was like,
yeah,
okay.
Uh,
when I was like an 11 days,
okay,
what do I need?
Where do I,
when do I need to be there?
And I just,
I trained with a,
an old training partner of mine,
this Guy Edward Romana Rosa.
We used to do colleague and some
Thai boxing and self defense stuff,
knife fighting,
all kinds of shit.
Right?
But we're all neophytes,
uh,
at the time.
But we did the best we could.
I would run up the hill from
Ballard to Phinney Ridge.
I would meet him.
We would either go to the park and he
would have me do stuff like throw on the
bag,
the big army duffle full
of gear that we had.
I'd throw that on and I'd hit tie pads
on an incline because it was fucking hard
as shit.
Right.
So I haven't checked up and I had a crawl,
walk up this hill and kick these pads
and then he would have me do stuff.
Like we didn't have mats
and things like that.
So I would just be on the carpet.
I just sit there and take a position,
be blindfold me and
just fucking jump on me.
There are many manuals.
It fully just jump on me and I'd have to
figure my way out of whatever was going
on.
I had to feel it.
I couldn't,
I couldn't Tabay sloppy.
I had to figure out what was going on
and get to where I needed to be and then
finish.
It's like some pink
panther type Shit Dude.
You know,
just jump out at them.
Yeah,
just come out of the,
out of the closet or whatever.
Kendo stick and taking me out.
I mean it wasn't far from it.
Uh,
but in the end it was about sharpening
the mental aspect of it and just being
like,
all right,
you're going to go out there and you're
going to destroy this guy no matter
what.
And I choked him
unconscious in two minutes.
What was it was about sort of like
making up the training as you go along,
trying to figure it out
and have real MMA gloves.
We had to make 'em out of harbinger,
a bad gloves.
We had to cut the bar out of the palm
and cut something else off and there you
go.
There's an MMA glove and then
we didn't have real trunks.
We didn't have,
I didn't have anything.
I mean there was no,
imma make gear that you could just,
I went to a sporting good store to get,
uh,
some of my other equipment
and they're like,
what do you need this for?
Like fighting wha what
are you talking about?
And even most of the time.
So my first one,
it was 97.
Then I would fight guys
whenever I could on mats here,
there,
whatever.
It wasn't like I was Doji Star,
Dojo storming back in college.
I would just,
hey,
I see you're doing martial arts.
That's pretty cool.
He trained a while.
Yeah.
What do you,
Oh,
I did American Kempo and Da da Da.
That's great.
Uh,
what do you think of the UFC?
Ever watch that?
Oh,
that's fucking bad ass man.
I love it.
That's cool.
Awesome.
I want to fight.
What?
We'll just,
uh,
we'll,
we'll negotiate the rules and uh,
we'll just fight right here.
Uh,
okay.
And it's just back off,
you know,
no gloves,
no nothing.
Like,
let's go.
Boom.
I remember picking up this dude from the
east coast and shooting in on a double
picking him up sky and him booms,
slamming the shit out of him and we had
this big cargo net and hung down because
there was all these,
uh,
full courts basketballers like three or
four full court basketball courts that
went,
uh,
perpendicular to this whole thing.
So are you're running up
and down on the other side,
cargo nets to keep balls from flying
over into this other and onto the matted
area.
And also,
uh,
there was a rock climbing wall
and some other little stuff,
so to keep the basketball
stuff in the basketball area.
And then there was like a little room
that they had built for a women's workout
room.
So there was little cardio machines,
a little windows that they could
look out across the mats and onto the
basketball courts.
People would stop playing basketball
and hang on the cargo net thing and just
cheer and Talk Shit and whatever.
That's mad max beyond Thunderdome.
I mean,
one man,
it wasn't a lot of people,
but I remember I skyride,
this big old dude slammed him,
wham.
He turns over and I throw my hooks in,
I splat and face first on the Mat and
I'm just 12 to six elbowing him in the
back until he quits.
You know,
just stuff like that.
And you know the best was always,
you'd see a guy talking to his buddies
about how tough he is hitting the heavy
bag downstairs and that would
be the dude I'd always like.
Oh Hey man,
I see you've got some experience.
You ever thought before like Oh yeah,
sure.
Whatever you want to fight.
Uh okay pal out.
Just like
you get your training.
Yeah,
because I had that first
fight and that goes,
that was really cool.
We want you to come back and
fight again in the summer.
And at this point I was just
the dip shit who had showed up.
It was like,
who the fuck is this guy?
How old were you back to 1919.
In fact,
this dude in line is talking to me just
making conversation cause I'm this new
face around and Charlotte
was trains at AMC and he's,
and he's already a pro and he'd be,
he'd been known.
So I'm just this kid from Montana and
their highs even though I'm from Ballard
and uh,
he's just asking me,
well,
where do you train?
Go?
Well,
you know,
I used to train,
church basement with this
other dude and whatever,
and I train it a Jim Harrison's,
uh,
Bushido Ashita conquer Hurghada and,
and uh,
uh,
and Missoula.
And there was like,
oh,
okay,
well a cool cause everybody
thinks I'm going to get murdered.
I fucking trained in church basements.
What fucking idiot is this guy?
Where did they find this moron?
He's going to get murdered.
Like I can't believe even the guy sitting
next to my mom filming it is cheering
for Chris,
kick his ass back to Montana.
And my mom's like,
I'll come on as my son right now.
He's like,
oh,
I know.
I'm just,
you know,
I'm just playing around and you know,
Chris,
Chris won't hurt him.
What was like your motivation back then?
Do you think that,
did you think that this is going to
be a career or were you just enjoying
yourself?
No,
I intended fully to,
this was a point there.
I told the people that are trained
with back at Jim Harrison's place,
which is by the way,
that is a put up or shut up,
no bullshit.
If you come in trying to be a big shot,
you will get your fucking teeth
knocked out and you don't,
that's not the place to
try and be a tough guy.
And,
uh,
Jim Harrison's is about as
tough and as mean as a come.
Uh,
he's,
he's a,
uh,
was a big help towards me
developing who I am as a fighter.
It was a first US light
heavyweight kickboxing champion,
and he was a judo champion.
He fought the bare knuckle
karate back in the day,
like with Chuck Norris and all of them.
He was a super foot Wallace's trainer.
This dude is legit.
And so when we'd get guys that come in
the gym and they'd start doing all this
stuff and acting pretty cocky,
and then we just take turns like,
Hey,
who's gonna kick the shit
out of this guy tonight?
So,
uh,
so I'm out there a training and I
said to the junior instructor there,
I said,
well,
you know,
hey,
my goal is by the time I'm
24 I want to be in the UFC.
And that just kind of chuckle and he goes,
by the time you're 24,
you're going to win the UFC.
They go,
fuck you thought there was a career
in this from the very beginning.
I watched the tapes in Japan.
I saw that you,
I just thought with this,
I don't know what kind of
a living one would make.
I imagine you could
probably sustain yourself,
but uh,
I knew that I would get a chance to
see the world and beat up it's people.
So that was your actual approach
like you from the very beginning,
the beaten up these guys
and the basketball court,
you were thinking,
well,
this is just training
towards my ultimate goal.
I need to fight.
I all,
these guys are showing up with 250 and
old records and all this crazy shit.
And I'm like,
I don't have to go under 50.
I better get the I'm way behind.
I better start fighting people,
you know,
what am I going to do when I re I
fight the guy that's got at least,
you know,
95 fights fun.
You should really write a
book about all this shit.
I know you were one of the,
I mean if you really think about it,
you were one of the pioneers
that there was.
You were around just a few years after
the beginning of the UFC and you know,
you won the UFC title.
What was that like five years
after you first started fighting?
Uh,
from 97 at [inaudible] oh
four oh four that you won?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Wow.
Why did I think it was?
No,
sorry.
2002,
yeah,
2002 because five years,
cause I wasn't working for the UFC
when you weren't five or six years of
training with three years
of three years of wrestling,
two years did judo.
That's pretty crazy,
man.
I was pretty cool.
I mean if you really
stop and think about it,
that is a really crazy path.
You really should write a book then.
We used to go to that.
I like to be around and worry about all
the people that would get thrown under
the bus.
Not on purpose.
Just man.
I've seen some shit.
I've heard some shit.
I've been around some shit.
I prefer to keep that on the DL.
That brings us to one of the things we
were supposed to talk about on this show
that we need to talk about.
Um,
John Wayne Parker was on the show and
John Wayne Parr who is a great guy.
I love him to death.
Uh,
I really enjoyed talking to him,
but he had one particular story that
pissed you off and it was a story about
training with you.
Uh,
it was before you fought men.
It's Haro in the new year show.
Yeah.
And um,
well let's just play it and we'll get
you a reaction to it because I know you
really want to talk about this.
He's got a little like catch
wrestling as a few sterndrive.
Uh,
it's,
you want to hear a funny story?
Sure.
Say,
I,
um,
I meet Cub Swanson.
Cub Swanson is cool dude,
and they're hanging out.
And then my first day,
Eric Paulson,
steam,
uh,
it's more tidy.
Okay.
And I'm the,
I'm the new guy.
I have no nothing.
No one knows who I am.
And then it's like,
I already post was like,
okay,
[inaudible] has put your gear on guys.
Okay.
So Josh Barnett,
you spa this way,
he points to me and,
uh,
suddenly start and I'll
moving around inside kick jab,
and then Josh story,
something I'm like out and,
you know,
I mean,
boom,
boom.
And I'm going again.
He throws to keep cool.
And then,
and then a quick,
he's a big dude.
He's a big dude in India
in fearing for my life.
Just,
just tapping a light.
And then,
uh,
we do two rounds.
After two rounds,
he takes his glove off and
he throws it across the room.
He takes a shim pad off,
throws it across the room,
he packs his bag,
he stole,
stolen is out,
and then,
uh,
they go on to Tokyo the
next day to find them.
The New Year's Eve.
Um,
pride tournament,
I forget who it was against.
Um,
and then a bet a week passes.
Josh loses his flight.
I get a phone call from Eric Paulson
about three or four days later,
ones once I get back.
And I said,
oh,
hey,
this is Eric.
Hey going,
um,
I just want to let you know that we
blame you on Joshua's loss because he was
fine right up until he spied you.
And then some kid that had never seen
before owned him in the spine and took
away all his confidence.
So when he got to Japan,
he was a,
and no
way this is a true story.
I kid,
you know,
well,
first of all,
how ridiculous,
or they to take a guy like you would,
they don't,
you know,
I was always just that.
And you go and the gym and it's like,
oh,
Yay.
You spot him off.
You can cut it off there.
So the,
the fight that you fought in Japan
for the new year show was the,
the,
uh,
Minotauro Nogueira fight,
right?
Which,
uh,
that was a fight.
What you,
it was very close fight.
And you actually had a leg lock lock?
No,
no,
no.
That was the,
the second time I fought him that year.
And uh,
it was definitely nasty
front choke on them.
Then he managed to just barely escape.
I picked him up and
slammed him on his head.
I,
I whacked out.
I'm a bit,
uh,
up top and down below,
but,
uh,
he pretty much stalled me out.
He tried to hold me
down most of the fight.
And uh,
in the end they gave him the decision,
in my opinion,
what they wanted was a trilogy.
So I think it was a bullshit decision.
But if I don't finish a guy and
that the judges make a shitty call,
oh,
well that's my fault.
Still not the judges,
but that's neither here nor there.
Right in the store.
Really pissed you off.
So express yourself well.
Well
first,
all the,
you could say,
ah,
this guy came in and,
and,
and I even made sure to go back through
my mental rolodex about this because
I'll be honest,
I had a pretty vivid memory about training
with John Wayne Bar because I knew
absolutely who he was.
And when he showed up,
I know he was not unknown to
all these people at the gym.
And not to mention Eric Paulson,
it,
we'll make sure to introduce if
somebody of notoriety came in,
if you showed up right now,
Joe,
if people had been living in a cave,
he would talk.
He would say,
this is Joe Rogan.
He did taekwondo,
he did this,
and now you may know he will.
He always makes sure that everybody who
shows up gets their due respect and is
introduced properly to everybody.
Uh,
John Wayne Park,
I watched him fight at the sands
before he came and trained with us.
I watched him fight Muay Thai.
I'd seen him fight in white tie
before I knew who his wife was.
Uh,
Angie Rivera,
I had seen her fight before.
I,
I know all about John Wayne par
before he'd ever gotten to our gym.
And he shows up and I'm going,
Oh fuck,
that's so fucking cool.
And I made a point to come
up to John and tell him,
I watched your fight at the,
at the sands.
I was there,
I've seen you five to know all about you.
And I deliberately spent time
training with John as much as I could,
as much as I could.
So here's the thing,
John had a MMA fight coming up against,
uh,
Tony,
Tony Brunello.
So he's an RGM to try and
figure out this whole MMA game.
And I even put extra time into
John trying to help him out,
trying to teach him about defending the
take down and try to be more defensive
as a grappler.
And you know,
we all,
everybody there was really
kind and helpful to him,
especially myself.
And I tried to spar with him
as many times as possible.
Why was at the gym,
because he is such a good fighter,
but at the same time he's
a lot smaller than me,
so I'm not trying to win.
I'm just trying to learn.
I'm not trying to take 250 pounds and
kick him and hurt him and bust him up and
make this a competition
about who's better.
If anything,
I would just play,
play,
play and you know his,
his striking is so
unorthodox versus a stand,
a boxing rhythm and,
and even what you might consider sometimes
the standard Thai boxing rhythm he
punches on on on weird
timing and where we're at,
timing signatures and weird rhythms
and his elbows are super high,
which normally people would be like,
that's Shitty,
but he makes it all work and he's got
a great kick in good reactions and good
footwork.
So we played a lot,
but there was never any
ass kicking on my part.
There was,
I never chucked my gloves across the
room because this new guy just showed up
and beat me up.
It's like,
that's all fucking bullshit.
Why do you think you would say that?
Maybe he's been punched in
the head too many times.
Maybe he sees that as his
opportunity to get some sort of fame.
I guess he's got a documentary out,
which,
you know,
I dunno what he's lying about in that,
but uh,
clearly this guy is delusional.
Um,
and even still,
there's like that unwritten
rule about training,
right?
You don't talk about it.
And you know,
that being said,
when we did spar,
there was at least there was one time
where I put him on the floor by accident,
just timed a right middle kick against
his right hand and it just clunked him
right?
And right in the right
spot down to the floor.
He goes and we laughed because we thought,
Huh,
I go,
I didn't throw that hard.
He goes,
man,
that was just,
that was just a hell a shift
that was really well placed.
And we just,
what we,
what did we do?
We figured out how to repeat
it because we thought,
Huh,
if if one could land that kicked,
just write be a great quick,
it'd be great thing to
have in one's arsenal,
especially if you're not
even trying to hurt someone.
They'd get hurt so bad.
The drug.
Well,
and,
and you know,
I got a big,
big heavy leg,
you know,
so I don't fault him for that.
It's,
no,
it's not like we're trying to win.
How many just sparked,
sparked him,
fuck,
uh,
six,
seven,
eight,
eight times,
whatever.
I mean,
he was there for a good bit
and then he disappeared,
which I guess he took
off to Thomas Denny's.
I don't know why,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's not like he was having to
pay to be at CSW at the time,
but,
uh,
you know,
when it came to MMA,
he got murdered on the feed in,
on the ground.
And not because he's a bad Stryker,
it's because he didn't
have the rhythm yet.
You know,
a little rhythm of stopping takedowns
there with the tension of the takedown
distance,
the clinch distance,
which,
which doesn't end,
uh,
you know,
all kinds of little things that
change the way you pattern your shots,
the way you would angle the
way you would foot work.
Uh,
so,
you know,
just in a straight Thai
boxing said scenario,
of course he's very relaxed.
But with MMA,
with everything that comes with it,
he's not so relaxed,
which is no fault of his.
Yeah.
He talked about not pursuing MMA because
he was such an expert in Moitai Thai
and he didn't like the fact that like
when he would do Jujitsu or wrestling or
anything,
he just was so out of his element.
He didn't,
didn't like being a beginner again.
What does that well,
you know,
but that's,
that's quitting.
That's what that is.
He wasn't fucking good at
Moitai to begin with either.
I promise you.
Right.
But he was by the time you started and
that's hard for people to start over.
It's like taking a guy who has,
here's the thing,
he,
by the time he started MMA,
he was already good at one thing.
He got so used to being good at one thing.
He couldn't stand to
be a white belt again.
Well then it definitely wasn't for you.
Right.
And a,
I guess you don't like potentially
learning new languages or a real reading,
new books,
learning,
that's fine.
You can stay in your little hole
and clearly MMA wasn't for him.
Some people though,
they get a little bit
of success a little bit.
Obviously he got a large
amount of success and money.
Do you think he made Thai boxing?
I mean,
very little.
Exactly.
So he probably thought MMA was going
to be a way to get more notoriety,
more money,
more whatever.
And then when he realized that wasn't
going to happen the way he thought it was,
he quit.
Well,
you'll see guys that have really decorated
Moitai careers and they struggle to
make it an MMA serial.
Dia Bata is good example is a guy
who's pretty successful in MMA.
He was pretty successful
but really good at Moitai.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
The world champion and Muay Thai and this,
that transition is,
is it ain't easy.
If it was easy,
everybody would do it.
That's true.
And uh,
but as far as kicking my ass at man has
never kicked my ass and his entire life.
That's weird.
And you know what's so weird
is I was a John Wayne Park Fan.
I meet the guy at my gym and make
a point to not only help him,
but to train with him,
to learn from him,
to have that experience,
to be there,
you'd be like,
Oh,
you know,
when am I going to get a chance to
train with John Wayne par again?
I wanted to have the both
of you on a podcast next.
It's going to be some fucking all could
happen is that he's just going to go,
well,
no,
it happened this way and I'm just like,
shut the fuck up.
You know what I mean?
Knocked me out right now then if
that's what you want to go along with.
But it's just dumb.
And a,
and then recently someone dug up the
whole Hector Lombard stuff again.
I'm like,
Oh,
why?
And I thought that was done because we
have a mutual friend through the gym and
he says,
Oh,
you know,
Hector,
you see,
sorry.
Apologize for all the crap before.
And I'm like,
that's cool.
You know,
we never had a problem
with Hector at CSW really?
And,
uh,
even the night that Hector
called me out at Bellator,
I did the day before weigh ins.
I'm Hector,
how are you doing man?
I think you're going to do really great,
you know,
blah,
blah.
Still backing him up.
And then only to have him say,
oh,
I want to fight this guy.
Like what the fuck man?
He said down at the Wayne.
When did say that after he won
his fight at Bella [inaudible],
this is when he was the mill,
the champion it.
But who do you want to fight next to me?
Like I want off fight Josh Barnett
and what we want to fight me for?
What the fuck dude come on
and people the wrong way.
You ruffling feathers.
What are you doing man?
You know what?
Maybe I will,
I will accept that I ruffle feathers.
I rub people the wrong way.
I will ruffle feathers,
especially in the case that I
will call things like I see it.
I don't let bullshit slide
and I have absolutely no,
I do not suffer fools.
So if you come at me with
a bunch of just ignorant,
stupid,
whatever,
if you built your whole life,
this whole construct around who you
are and what you do based on a lie,
based on something fall,
something bullshit.
Some I'm just,
I'm not going to accept that and I'm not
going to respect you if you don't have
to be the best.
You could be the worst.
But if you're an honest person,
you're a real person,
then I don't give a shit that's not,
I'm not really impressed by people that
can try to portray being something that
they aren't or make themselves
into something that they aren't.
I'm more interested in the people who
are exactly who they are and that's fine
and understanding that they
have weaknesses and strengths
and being able to grow
and and be a person of integrity and being
a person that is true to who they are
and true to me.
So that will cause a lot
of issues with folks,
especially the fact is
ideal in entertainment,
whether it be fighting,
are they acting or anything that I do.
There's a lot of false bravado.
A lot of made up,
uh,
you know,
machismo posturing,
right.
So,
Hector,
the first time,
so he says the reason that we had beef
was because he broke my nose the first
day of sparring and I hated him ever.
I want to,
I hated him ever since then.
And that's not fucking true either.
The first day he ever showed up at CSW,
he'd come up from team quest.
He wasn't going to train there anymore.
And,
uh,
I think he still hates Dan Henderson.
Uh,
why does it hit Dan Henderson?
I don't know that whatever.
I don't,
I never asked.
I just,
Oh,
he,
he sucks,
man.
He's a Jerky Myeong whatever,
you know,
my,
I didn't get into it,
but the first thing he came and sparred
was actually one of the best days we
ever had with sparring
because he got in the ring.
He wasn't trying to murder everybody.
And uh,
you know,
I fucking hit Victor Rolls Autumn
and took his knee and he's just like,
holy shit,
that's crazy.
How did you do?
We're all having a good time,
but I'm tapping them out
and taking them down,
whatever.
But there's no animosity.
We,
everybody's training and training and
training and he's always amping it up now.
And then at some point I show up at
practice late and everyone's on the floor.
Hecker doesn't have a partner.
So I just threw my shit on real quick.
No hand wraps,
no nothing.
No one's going hard.
Like I'm just going to jump
in and start warming up.
All right.
Touch,
touch,
tap,
tap.
Oh boom.
He throws the biggest
fucking punch he's gotten,
tries to knock me out,
starts my nose bleeding.
I'm just going,
what the fuck?
So then it's all on for like 20 minutes
and I put a giant egg on the side of his
head and shit and then pause.
And you basically had a fight.
It was broad it out and uh,
with,
you know,
boxing,
kickboxing and Paula finally called,
called an nine to it and it's fine.
And then later on,
at some point he sparring mighty moe
and mighty moe drops him and Paul like,
all right,
all right.
So,
you know,
lighten it up.
Lighten it up.
Fuck man,
I ain't scared of him.
I ain't scared and mighty mo was like,
man,
fuck you.
What?
I don't need this.
I'm here to help you out.
I already got x amount
of cars and two houses,
whatever.
You know what?
I don't need this shit.
I've already made money.
You're the one who's down here
trying to crawl up the ranks.
You know,
why you,
what are you going to get out of this?
And so then things started
getting a little worse here.
He started beating up on civilians,
which is what I call like
people that are not pros.
And uh,
and we would still spar and
things like that here and there.
But I always knew that with Hector,
he was always going to go hard.
You never had a light?
Not because he couldn't,
but he wouldn't.
And you guys,
after you'd gone hard for 20 minutes,
you basically fought
it out for 20 minutes.
I was done with it.
I'd never,
I wasn't mad at him.
So you were perfectly fine
with sparring him after that.
He was,
he made it clear who he
was going to be in the gym.
Oh,
that's fine.
I mean,
one time we had a,
a grappling tournament.
I drove him out with me
so we could all hang out,
everyone could be together.
Uh,
he came out to this fight out in palm
desert where we had some guys fighting and
I mean,
every,
he was a part of everything with,
with part of the team,
but we knew that he was unstable,
but we knew what to expect.
So Bob Lou beat up on him one time in
the gym because he didn't like him at all
because he was,
he would beat up on because Hector
would take liberties of people,
right.
That he,
that Babaloo felt like,
well,
you shouldn't do that.
And,
uh,
but uh,
then the last time we sparred,
uh,
I get on top of him and I,
and I'm working him over pretty good,
but I'm not trying to kill the guy.
And he freaks out and he's like,
oh,
I'm good.
You know what?
I'm tired,
man.
Why is like,
what,
what do you mean you to I do every day
you go hard and try to kill people in the
one day.
You don't want to go hard,
you don't say anything,
but everybody just expects
us what's going to be bright.
And so he says,
oh,
and this one day I got on top of him,
beat him near within an inch of his life.
And I'm like,
I didn't do that.
I know I didn't do that.
Yeah,
I did.
I pinned him and you know,
I was,
I was leather and m but
not hurting the guy,
you know,
and uh,
he thought he was going
to die or something.
I'm like,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna do that to you.
It's just,
it's just training.
And uh,
now it's like this thing again,
it's like,
you know,
you didn't beat my ass in the gym.
You're an incredible fighter.
In fact,
you're a better fighter
than you even understand.
Hector Lombard,
if his head was right,
would be untouchable.
He is one of the most gifted,
strong,
fast at throw aside the fact that
he just got popped for steroids.
Even with,
even with it,
you could,
you could find him,
his fucking his peers and give them
all the same shit or different shit.
It doesn't matter.
They're not going to move.
Have the strength and the speed.
Like Hector's Hector's unreal.
Hector's should be undefeated,
the Hector's a headcase and that's why,
you know,
he'll never fully ascend to the top of
the throne or really keep it if he can
get there because he doesn't understand
what it is that he has and how to use it
best,
but he is amazing.
Don't get me wrong.
That dude gnarly.
Yeah.
He's a super athlete.
There's no doubt about that.
I've never seen anybody
ragdoll Jake shields like that.
He could judge shields around.
He could do that to anybody
in his weight division.
He can he can he now could somebody
have a counter for some something?
Yeah.
I'm not saying he's,
he's invincible,
but I'm saying that what he possesses
and athleticism and skill sets.
He's actually a good leg lock her too.
You won't see them necessarily go for it,
but he is a good leg locker.
Yeah.
There's a video of him in
a grappling tournament.
Breaks that guy's leg.
Yeah,
it's loud but a carrot and he's got,
he's got even more
skills than he displays.
But again,
you know,
you gotta be able to put it together.
But isn't that part of the beauty of MMA
is that it is this weird thing that you
just,
you can't just be a super athlete
because there's other super athletes too.
You can't just be a technical guy cause
there's other guys that are technical
too.
There's so many variables.
That's true.
And you could be the
best athlete out there.
I know I fought people that were bigger
and stronger than me and faster and I've
beaten them before and it wasn't
because I went and I fought there.
Their speed with my speed or,
or use my strength against their strength.
It was,
I found a way to bypass those things
or to put them in such a way that they
wouldn't even apply strength
or speed it where they should,
they don't even understand that,
that it's still available to them.
It's just that they don't
understand the position.
They don't understand what's going on.
They don't even realize what
opportunities are there for them.
Well,
isn't it almost impossible unless
you spend decades in martial arts,
it's all almost impossible to have all
the skills and all the knowledge at your
disposal.
Of course,
it's such a deep pool of
information to draw from.
It is,
but you know,
if you want to have the
biggest toolbox out there,
then you have to spend the time to do it.
When the coaches are done coaching
you and you've left practice,
how do you spend your time?
Are you watching video not just on your
opponent but just watching video on
things for fun or or to beat or two to
take a look at something and break it
down and make it yours and in
a very highly technical aspect?
Or are you a shadow boxing to make
sure that the work on keeping that jab
inside?
Are you thinking about the things
that you've been working on?
Are you thinking about every
mentally drilling like gable says,
are you sitting there going
through shot after shot,
after shot,
set up after set up after
set up in your head?
Are you having a garbage truck come
through in the signal right now?
[inaudible] garbage trucks right now that,
what's that?
Is that what
that was popping in the hood?
Most of y'all can't even hear that.
They're up there.
Like,
I got a fucking hot spot,
motherfucker.
Bring me your trash and your
recyclables and check your email.
If you,
if you were going to start someone,
spam goes.
Yeah,
I know you trained with a bunch of young
fighters now you chain a bunch of young
fighters right now.
Jessamine Duke,
uh,
Marina Shaffir,
Victor Henry show.
Hey,
I'm a moto Coleen Schneider Shana.
And if you wanted to start it,
say if you're going to start from scratch,
if you were going to develop a program
and take a athletes that had never fought
before,
never had any martial arts
experience whatsoever,
and turn them into professional,
mixed martial arts fighters.
If you had a,
a,
a curriculum as it were,
how would you start that off?
Uh,
first,
first things first.
What do you possess up top your brain.
Exactly.
If you don't have the type of
mind that can be that dedicated,
that obsessive that,
that can,
that can be easy going and you need to
be easy going and be completely unmovable
when you need to be.
Yeah.
That unshaking and unfettered confidence.
And how would you
develop that in a person?
Is that something you either
have or you don't have,
or is it something that you could develop?
You can develop it,
but it's,
I truly believe that for the most part,
it's something that you are
born with the ability to do.
Uh,
you,
you give them adversity right off
the bat and you give them struggles.
You give them things that
will confuse them on purpose.
And you see,
how do they deal with that?
Do they quit and they fold it in and they
throw a fit about it and they throw a
temper tantrum?
How do you,
because what you have to do to get
to the end goal is really irrelevant.
Getting to the end goal
is what's important.
So if you had to fucking do coffee
runs for two weeks in a row,
if that was all,
I mean,
come on.
What is that in the length of what your
career would be in length of what your
training would be?
Coffee runs.
What do you mean?
When one said,
hey,
Josh wants you to go get them coffee.
Yes.
How the fuck is that
going to help anybody?
I just made it up because
I've been drinking coffee,
but,
but uh,
if that was it,
just to see them,
you're like,
well,
I want to go train.
I want to see what they do.
Well,
don't you think that you're
dealing with people like,
okay,
some people will come to the table with
a certain amount of mental toughness,
a certain amount of discipline,
a certain amount of,
uh,
the ability to overcome
adversity and some people won't.
And you're only going to
take the ones that will,
is it,
is it possible to take someone who's
almost essentially a blank slate
athletically and turn them into someone
who could understand what's going on in
their mind?
Like,
do you believe in like mental training?
Yes,
it is possible.
But again,
they would have to exhibit
those characteristics.
Not through an athletic window per se,
but just through a
determination standpoint,
uh,
just through,
you know,
it's like the reason why pro-wrestling
gyms and back in the day,
or even even currently,
uh,
in,
in Japan especially,
and the lion's den and the,
they had tryouts.
I had to go through a tryout.
I beat to profilers,
my first two fights and I still
had to go through a tryout.
I still had sparring.
I still had,
I had to have a meeting with the coaches
before I could join AMCs fight team
because just winning,
just,
even being a good fighter wasn't enough.
They needed to see what
does this guy made of?
Is He coachable?
Is He,
um,
is he have the mental capacity to
be in this environment and excel?
Can he,
can he be one of those people
that what we instill in him,
we'll stick.
Well,
that was what I was kind of getting to,
is there a way you could
develop a mental curriculum?
Because it seems like that is
one of the biggest parts of,
of competing one of the
biggest parts of succeeding.
And I'm not tripping over your own Dick.
Right.
Which a lot of people do in
all sorts of things in life.
You see with standup Comedians,
you see it with musicians,
you see with authors,
there's people that just don't fucking
do the work or they fuck up or they don't
fall through or they
take too much time off.
Or w w the mental aspect of success,
the,
the idea of finding a goal,
figuring out how to get to that goal and
then avoiding anything that trips you
up along the way.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't know about building a curriculum
that's one size fits all because
everybody's a little different.
But,
uh,
of,
of the difficulties that you,
that you named are,
uh,
a failing or,
you know,
not trying to wear some
of these posey yeah.
Sometimes it is.
Sometimes it's very tight and small.
Sometimes you just never
know what you're getting at.
I met Nikki said in rocky.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the thing.
Uh,
some of those things are okay.
Failing is okay.
As long as you learn from it,
it's one of the best motivators ever.
What's not okay is distractions
not doing the work.
Not,
there's a difference between not being
successful because it just isn't learned
yet.
Isn't,
isn't.
You haven't developed the capability yet.
Maybe you're just not quite strong enough.
Quite fat.
Things like that.
Things that you in time can be
learned and understood and grown from.
And then there's shitting the
bed by not putting the work in,
by having the wrong attitude,
by showing up,
trying to win all the time,
letting your ego get in the way.
Uh,
things like that.
And that's what you want as a coach as,
okay.
Not even just as a coast was take the
coaching aspect out of it because this
applies to life as someone that's going
to have somebody else apprentice under
them as somebody that has the ability
to instill knowledge and understanding
towards something that somebody
else wants to work towards.
That person who needs to learn this
stuff has to have the right head.
My old coach,
Billy Robinson said,
you need to learn how to learn,
and that's a fucking fact.
And so the coat,
one of the mentors jobs is to try and
help guide this person to teach them how
to learn.
Because once they learn,
it's the,
it's the stupid old analogy of
give a man a fish he'll eat today.
Teach a man to fish.
He'll eat for a lifetime.
It is fucking that simple.
When broken down to its smallest pieces,
you have to learn how to fish
and you learn how to fish.
It doesn't matter if I tell you,
okay,
well I want you to use your jab
to score on this guy's chin.
You will figure out the way you need
to use your jab to score on that guy's
chin.
You will make the jab that you possessed,
the most effective jab you have ever known
because you understand,
you know how to fish.
You're not sitting there getting pissed
off because you don't like the fact that
you didn't hit him every
time or you didn't.
You're you're,
you're,
you're focusing on the wrong things.
You're too busy trying to win
instead of trying to learn.
Once you learn,
you'll win.
If he tried to win all the time,
you're going to fail.
Eventually does a big,
that's a big problem in Jujitsu.
Marcello Garcia talks about that a lot.
He says that you have to open yourself
up and training and you can't worry about
being tapped.
Nope.
Being tapped as a part of the game.
Get tapped and just move on.
Don't worry about it.
That's right.
It's what's most important is that you
open up your game and then in open,
instead of being like super defensive
and never taking any chances trying to
win,
you don't,
you don't learn because you don't,
you don't get tapped.
But you don't learn Jack Shit and
there's always those guys like a,
every gym has that.
God.
It's almost impossible to tap.
It doesn't fucking tap anybody.
Right.
That's true.
And,
and what?
Yeah,
that's another thing that as a mentor,
as a coach or whatever
you want to call it,
that you have to look for is not the
person is there's always the person that's
just fresh.
The boat,
you know,
they just fell off the turnip truck,
whatever.
Just getting into it.
Turn up trucks,
turn up trucks.
That's an old one.
That's old school.
Well,
the school is stable.
I mean there's turnip trucks that go
through those feelings all the time.
Oh,
they're all about condoms over there.
There one turnip truck for the
whole entire state of California.
It's organic.
It is organic to turn traits.
Gluten free.
Gluten free turnip.
Yeah.
I'm not worried about booting
anymore mean either sugar and gluten,
but that's what the gluten issue is.
It's not like I'm,
the real issue I believe with
gluten is that gluten is all sugar.
Like when you're not dot gluten,
but gluten containing products.
If you have a lot of bread,
if you have a lot of pasta,
a lot of sugar,
and the real issue is she glycemic carbs.
That's the real issue.
But it seems to be,
and I've talked to nutritious
about and they're like,
well some people are more sensitive and
some people are the people that are most
sensitive,
it's usually
cause they're Pachulia
is interacting with,
ah,
yeah,
sure.
It's,
it's a,
uh,
you know,
Crystal's and gluten,
haven't they?
They are the ones where they're,
the intolerance is
within that combination.
Not the person themselves.
I get it.
Yeah.
The body's okay with gluten,
but if you have crystals
on it at the same time,
depending on what harmony's,
they're vibrating at,
that gluten could be an
issue is very important.
But,
uh,
I knew a girl named harmony.
She annoying.
Oh my goodness.
Look,
color was orange.
It's kind of a purpleish.
But that,
that whole thing,
that gluten thing is like,
there's some to it.
Like you're not really supposed
to be eating bread all the time.
You're not really supposed to be
eaten pasta all the time and your body
somewhat.
Obviously some people have a harder
time processing all kinds of different
foods.
Everybody's diet.
It's going to be different to the person,
but the one thing that
will help everybody,
everybody listening to this,
if you're here,
all this gluten frat is
cut the fucking sugar out.
Just cut it way back.
Eat Fruit.
If you want some sugar,
have a peach.
I have a pair.
It'll make a giant difference.
Totally getting off top.
We're digressing,
but,
but we're not because we
were talking about learning,
right?
Learning true.
And one of the things even about the
whole concept of this gluten stuff,
right?
And bread and pasta.
How refined is the shit you're eating too?
Like if you had bread that was almost
as as least refined as possible.
I mean it's going to be refined to some
degree because you made it into fucking
bread,
but the least refined as possible,
like sprouted grains is way
different from cheese ball,
white bread,
wonder bread type shit.
Salt,
sugar.
Yeah,
I'm cheese ball,
white bread and I've been
known to be unhealthy.
You're a little cheesy,
but it's,
it's amusing.
I love sprouted bread.
I like like a Zeke,
you'll bread and stuff like that.
I'm not,
my body doesn't seem to
react to that bad at all,
but it does tend to burn a
little bit on initial uh,
touch from me.
But that's because I'm just
so unholy and say tonic.
That's the problem.
The [inaudible] no,
it's just like starts glowing hot.
I didn't know you were unholy.
Ensay tenant,
all of the above.
How long have you been unholy?
Uh,
I think since the day I was born,
I think when I was born out
of that sign or something.
Or You,
have you been down since I began to crawl
on the night I was born,
I heard the moon turn of fire red.
But uh,
so you get these,
these new guys,
but they're sprouted grain bread and
their beats and you get them to a certain
point.
Right.
And then here's the real trouble.
They experience some success.
They get to some point of understanding
and of they feel like they know what
their game is and they
know where they can win.
Getting that motherfucker
out of that hole,
out of that Shell,
that's hard and that's unfortunately
where a lot of times you just got to turn
to a guy and be like,
hi,
I'm done with you.
That's it.
You have set your own
limitation at this point.
You have,
you have created your own roadblocks
and you don't even understand it.
Sort of like what you were
talking about with John Wayne.
Par like John Wayne Pard not wanting to
learn how to rappel because he was so
good at Moitai eatery,
cross the Gulf and become an expert
and didn't want to become a beginner.
Exactly.
John Wayne Card decided he was going
to be a failure in terms of grappling
and MMA.
He decided that it wasn't a matter of
whether he could be successful or he are,
you know,
he could be mildly successful.
Greatly successful,
who knows,
but he decided that he
was going to not be good.
I had this guy,
he wasn't sure.
I had this conversation
with a God wants about,
uh,
this guy who's an MMA fighter.
I don't want to name his name,
but he's a really good kickboxer who gone
into MMA and kept getting tapped out.
And this guy said,
well he just doesn't have
any talent for Jujitsu.
And I said,
that's crazy.
I go,
it's not that he doesn't
have any talent for Jujitsu.
I go,
I'll tell you exactly what
happens because I know those guys,
they are so good at kickboxing.
They don't want to do Jujitsu cause if
they do Jujitsu or submission wrestling
or whatever the fuck it is,
they're going to get tapped out and
they don't like getting tapped out.
So they spend as little time doing that
as possible and as much time hitting the
pads in the bag,
working on their strengths,
not work on the weaknesses.
No one likes to feel like
they're failing or you know,
it's,
it's a hard thing for people to do it
to go back to sucking again in some way.
And I just started training kickboxing,
karate and La.
One of my students show he Yamamoto
is a junior world champion and uh,
you know,
junior world champion [inaudible],
he's taken third and fourth
and the weight category,
a champion world championships.
He is also the youngest guy to ever
compete in the world open weight.
He was like 185 pounds or so at the time,
19 years old or so.
And he made it to top 32
top whatever he fought.
Like Glau they or someone in law,
something like that.
Wow.
Fucking kid.
I know.
Cut Out Day has a lot to offer.
I know all martial arts have something
to offer and I've always thought that
kill chain was a,
was a bad ass art and it'd be fun to do.
And so what I do,
I show up,
guess what?
I got to be a white belt.
I had to go buy a cut out the [inaudible].
I had the,
I have to sit there and sit in the back
of the line with everybody else and be
nobody.
And that's okay because people go,
I don't understand.
How come,
how come you're here with
a white belt training?
Conte doing forms and because
I like being a white belt,
I like learning and in a way it's kind
of like my yoga because I can throw a
sidekick,
but if you make me do sidekick
from that with the heels,
tea,
it's just a different way of doing it.
I don't know.
These forms,
I don't know,
some of these positions to
do these sorts of things,
so it makes my body stretch and adapt
and all I'm doing is getting better,
learning more.
It doesn't mean that I have to go out
there and Sanchia in with my knees and and
whatever and give somebody
a karate chop in the neck.
It's but
so learning new movements.
Yes.
It's always good to learn new movements.
You were here once and you were saying
that after you left here you were going
to go train savant.
Yep.
Yeah.
I've trained savant for
about a couple of years.
I've never done any savant training.
What does what do it?
Love it.
Okay.
Here's the simplest way I can,
I can describe savant,
uh,
think of [inaudible] as like the western
boxing equivalent of kickboxing gear
more Floyd Mayweather.
Then you are,
you know,
my exam,
it is
hitting and getting hit.
The idea of Nevada,
it's a touch and not get touched.
Lots of footwork using
your lead leg lead hand,
uh,
tons of footwork.
So does not a lot of emphasis on power.
No.
I mean you develop power and,
and,
and you have your kill shot opportunities.
But really it's about being scoring off,
balancing angling w there's a great
fight Raymond deckers versus Pinocchio.
This Italian Slovak guy and it's fine.
Fine.
Yeah.
If I will check with Jamie and
Christ Pinocchio Beats with vectors.
Get the fuck you're watching it.
Wait a minute.
This dude beat Ramon Dekkers off
savant guy beat Ramon Dekkers.
Yup.
Oh,
five rounds.
Decker like five.
No,
he was,
he was a kid.
No,
he was at least seven and a half.
I think John Wayne Parr had just beat
him up really bad and practice and his
confidence was shot.
So a Pinocchio beats deckers.
But how he does it is by scoring more,
but being elusive.
And you watch the two fighters and
you can see it absolutely different.
This Nokia is a real boy.
So,
uh,
it's Panofsky oh bro.
You Watch deckers and
deckers is full of power,
tons of power.
And when he kicks,
you can see this just bone
shattering type stuff.
What year was this?
Early nineties.
Or Ramon was still under the prime.
Oh yeah,
he,
Ramon was still knocking
out ties over in Thailand.
But the thing is Pinocchio was
almost never there to get hit.
And the other thing is when
he's taking these shots,
he slides and moves with them.
He always takes the power out of it
and there's quite a few times he kicks
deckers legs out from underneath
them while he's trying to,
he's trying to wind up on them really,
and tags him with a lot of shots
with up top with the hands.
This is very interesting.
And it's not,
the deckers is worst
fighter than Pinocchio.
Don't turn it into that kind of thing.
You know,
listeners,
it's about style right here.
This is what it came down to.
It was a guy using a
different tactic against,
uh,
you know,
he's not gonna match power with this
dude who could Raymond and was just a
destroyer.
Too much power kicked
in the Dick Right there.
Now they're wearing those shoes.
Why are they wearing the,
some sort of fucking your whatever
European leagues thing about,
you know what I mean?
This is back in the day when
kickboxing was different,
everywhere you went in.
This is kickboxing.
There's no clinch.
There's no clinch,
no claims,
no elbows,
no knees.
What do you think about that?
Like the glory rules
as opposed to full moy?
Moitai uh,
[inaudible] has a tendency to get boring
as shit when they get in the clinch and
there there's throwing side on the after
side knee and no one's really landing
anything of,
and they're hanging on each other
and I understand why they want,
uh,
you know,
people to be at that
mid range or long range,
just tagging each other,
uh,
because it looks more exciting to the,
to the casual fans.
I kind of get it from that perspective,
but I don't like it as far as uh,
a style.
You see that lead leg hook kick
and then invaded his low return,
low kick at the same time.
It was barely a,
it was more like a ax kick.
It looked like a slap.
I don't foot slap inside low high again,
and he's just moving a lot constantly.
And look,
it's just spinning off of his kick
and sliding away as he's kicking.
Yeah.
Pinocchio also beat,
uh,
or well,
you don't want Voss fought,
uh,
in some matches too in lost.
Wow.
So I mean it's just apply it.
So I love Hook,
kick to the face.
I love the,
the distancing,
the speed.
You know,
one of the things I like to do use if
at all possible on teach to people is
that,
you know,
what,
how much do you think your leg ways,
oh my 30,
40 pounds,
if you just got it up there as
fast and as quick and as con.
And it's to the point as possible if
you score as clean as possible and as
quick,
I don't need to throw hard,
I mean forces is a mass
times velocity squared,
so let's work on the velocity squared
and not trying to generate more,
more uh,
uh,
strength into that movement.
But just speed,
right?
So mean or killed kitchen style,
then Muy Thai style.
Well,
Kilcoyne has a tendency to kick,
try to really kick the baseball
bat to part two at times.
But with savant,
I mean if you can even watch some of the
old American kickboxing stuff back in
the day and those guys were so adept at
going from foot to hand to hand to foot
and foot the hand,
obviously it was tailored to the game.
But if you thought,
you know,
just watch a Guy Metzger,
uh,
what's his Arona they're
out there in this bit,
just a nice little kick lead leg,
high kick and this whack and all of a
sudden a Rhone is on roller skates and it
didn't even look like much.
Yeah.
You seeing that sometimes today we
are seeing more of a karate style.
Like Machida is a perfect
example is no windup.
There's no step before he
throws the back round kick.
Well he just throws it
right from their pedis.
Does that as well?
Yeah.
You've seen a lot of guys that are front
kicks taking people out as if that was
never a legit technique.
You know what I mean?
And there's a bazillion
ways to throw front kick.
You can throw a tie us to,
I'll push kick.
You could throw the
taekwondo one where you like.
Victor Webster has one of the nastiest
push kicks ever and he'll fuck and he's
out here and he steps in,
he rides into it and then he hits you
right in the hip and makes you sit on the
floor.
It was like,
fuck dude,
that sucks.
He just stomps right through your
hip and then you've got cut out.
They style,
we pick it up and fold it and then punt
as Jim Harrison would say with the ball
of the foot and you get
them right in the chin,
the solar plexus,
diaphragm area.
You could turn it over like
Savannah likes to do and,
or even Kilcoyne has it too.
That's a,
uh,
Kiko knows,
kick the McCaw Zwicky Gary and punt
it right into the liver and it's,
you know,
ball of the foot.
How much surface area is that?
It's just a,
the end of the Hammer,
the head of the hammer
hitting right into the point.
And then there's a lot of
old school taekwondo guys
that would throw round kicks
butt.
They would throw it and land the
ball of the foot like a front kick.
Sure.
That was
a big thing that used
to do back in the day.
Kicked it where at the air,
Paulson ways Ho holds this camp.
Uh,
every year it's a big full on,
there'll be multiple instructors teaching
all this stuff and all these people
come from all over his affiliate gyms
and they pile into our gym during our
training time.
So he just integrates everyone together.
And I always just tell Paul and I go,
don't stick the Newbie fucking
goof balls in there with me.
If I've got a fight coming
up and these user in here,
they're going to get wrecked like that.
That's,
this is not my job to help this
dude have a good time at camp.
I'm getting ready.
Please just don't do it,
right.
No,
you could just,
you could just take it easy.
I'm like,
no,
they're not going to go easy on me for
one because I'm me and they want to
either they're excited,
scared,
or want to prove something,
so I don't want it.
I don't even want to deal with it.
But if I have to,
I'm burying them.
So that's just the way it is.
So anyways,
we're in there.
We're kickboxing that
this kid and fucking,
he turns it up.
I'm like,
God damn it.
So what do I do?
I step up,
throw a left high,
kick off the lead leg,
but I turn it over to hit
with the ball of the foot.
I just stabbed him right
in the jaw with it.
He stuns,
puts his hand up quits for the whole day.
He's done.
He says that,
I don't,
I'm done.
Forget it.
It was probably a good idea.
It was lovely.
It was a good idea.
I got a concussion for all I know.
Whenever we learn,
that's my problem with tournaments.
Like especially those are
kickboxing tournament,
they're doing,
large guys are,
they're getting essentially
knocked out in their first fight.
They recover,
you know,
they,
they get dropped or stunned or
fucked up and then they have like,
you know,
20,
30 minutes for everything to cool down
and really hurt and then they get back in
there and do it again.
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
And uh,
I was just having this conversation
with somebody the other day about,
uh,
I was with a referee actually,
and I go,
you know,
we need tournaments back in MMA.
And he's like,
and they go,
well,
you know,
we can run a tournament.
And I go,
no,
I know the fucking stupid
ruling where they say,
oh,
as long as you don't exceed a five,
five minute rounds in a night.
And I go,
that doesn't,
if I'm fighting pro boxing,
I'm out there for 36 minutes.
You're telling me that an MMA
fighter can't go 36 minutes.
If it was,
if you gave me 36 minutes,
then you could go to fives
and three fives and a final.
And he was like,
well,
there's guys who can barely
get through one five now.
I go,
Oh fuck good.
Hopefully they get the shit kicked out
of them and they fucking figure it out.
Either a,
how to be able to go past the five or B.
This ain't the sport for you.
I mean,
we're not supposed to make it.
So when you're a professional,
everybody doesn't need
to be able to compete.
When you're an amateur.
I have some understanding.
Everyone should be able
to get in the ring with,
with a modest amount of training,
uh,
to go out there and do it,
but not pros.
Why do you think that they
should bring back tournaments?
Every combat sport in the
world has tournament day,
everything.
And we love it.
We love the shit out of tournaments.
Japan loves everything.
Fighting and going to tournaments
so much they fucking make,
they'll have a TV show and it's battle.
And there was a piece of celery
versus a Yam like which is,
I don't even know how you
compare those tube or why,
how you make them fight.
They didn't even give him a little
knives or anything,
but for a shield and tried and salary
fighters don't want to do tournaments
because they feel like,
like say if there's a four man tournament,
you have a fight in the first round and
you win in 10 seconds by knockout and
then they go to rounds and there's a draw.
So they go to a third
round and it's brutal.
They're all bang the fuck up and then
they have to fight you in the finals and
you went through 10 seconds of
fighting and they've been good.
They've got the fuck beat out of
them and they're all banged up.
It should have been a
better fighter I guess.
Is that really what it is?
What if the draw is what have you
got fade or and a your opponent,
God willing to wimp willy the wimp
in his Cadillac coffin and willy,
the Wimp guy.
K owed and the first
round and then you went,
or what if it's raining hard rounds
and then the other guy gets
Vandelay and he's cro cop.
Yeah,
well you did do that,
but fuck it.
You know what I did?
I laid in the back,
I had ivs,
I had ice on me.
And honestly the biggest problem
wasn't even the fighting,
it was getting heat exhaustion before
you even showed up for the tournament
because dead summer of Orange County and
we had no air conditioning whatsoever.
No breezeways and that old gym.
And I started off doing 10 minute rounds,
just going through name profilers,
owning them,
and then all of a sudden eight minutes,
then six minutes,
then for then I can barely get a two
minute round off without falling apart.
And I'm just going,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
And then people start packing me with
ice bags in between rounds and in between
sessions.
And all of a sudden my energy
would start to come back.
Some I just go,
oh well this is fucked.
Oh Wow.
Let's get over there and do it.
So you were training and
as you were training,
you had no air conditioning in the gym
and you're getting a heat exhaustion.
It was fucking a hundred
degrees outside at times.
Fucked with your conditioning when you
actually went to fight because you never
were able to push by the time tosh.
But I mean there were things
like when Nogueira mounted me,
right,
I gave him my arm on purpose because I
couldn't get them off of mount because I
couldn't expand.
That kind of energy just wasn't there.
So if he,
I know if he goes to try and arm bar me,
that shit ain't going to happen.
So this is just because of the,
all the time that you spent in
the gym under heat exhaustion.
Yes.
So you,
you were never able to do
those 10 minute rounds,
those long rounds in the gym because just,
no,
it just got too hot.
Why didn't you guys would fucking
air conditioning and your gym?
Not My gym,
not my decision.
Now Eric Paulson has Jim.
Yeah.
Was it cesium?
But fuck,
I,
uh,
I love,
I struggled
to,
uh,
to get back,
until it took me about until next year
before I really finally fucking felt
better again.
When I find master law,
I was still just struggle.
My,
my CNS was shot central nervous system.
Oh yeah.
My adrenals is from,
from the helix you off so bad.
Wow.
What about Kronk Gym?
The fucking Detroit,
they would crank up the
heat and I hate that shit
is I'm more susceptible to it,
I think than others because
I'm so white viking like that.
If,
you know,
a little bit of cold would probably
would have done me some good.
Right.
If you were,
yeah.
Some African dude in
there sparring with you,
you'd have an advantage.
But,
uh,
some people don't take the heat as
well as others and some people do.
You know,
it's just a matter of fact.
And,
and here's the thing,
I got over there.
I fought my ass off.
I was exhausted.
I could have been bowed out and be like,
oh no cro cop,
he's,
he's gonna,
he's just going to walk over into the
finals and everybody who was going to be
like,
oh,
he had a really tough fight with Nogueira.
That's acceptable.
We'll give him a pass on that,
but I wouldn't give me a pass.
Fuck that.
So what did I do?
They put ice bags on anything.
It was banged up.
Doctors came back,
gave me an ivy and some vitamins and a
hung it off of the locker door and I just
laid on the ground and I had been gloomy
Fuji with me and my ex girlfriend at
the time and Eric and [inaudible] and
my friends with me and I just was there
with them.
And the refs come,
the officials come back and go,
so are you going to fight the last fight?
And like,
yes,
I am damn right I am,
because that's what a man does.
And uh,
I fought,
it doesn't run,
man does is in a tournament.
[inaudible] get the fuck out of here.
You know,
I didn't show up to,
to take second place.
I showed up to take first
or die trying and uh,
fuck it,
you know?
But why do you think that that
it's better to have a tournament?
Like what is it about it?
Just because the public
anticipates having those fights,
watching how it plays out.
Interesting to see how,
I mean,
come on,
look at March madness.
It's one of the biggest things ever.
And if it wasn't a tournament,
people would not be as excited.
But that's a terminal over
a long period of time.
They're not to a bunch
of games in a night.
That's actually a perfect
example of why it doesn't apply,
but it just,
I just mean the concept of tournaments
and even doing tournament's over over
time,
it's still great to,
but the one night tournament is,
well,
let's see who comes out on top.
Plus it's a great way to try and read,
establish a orders.
So you,
if,
let's say you have a whole bunch of pool,
they got a handful of all these guys and
you don't know who really fits where,
boom,
they go through this one night tournament.
Oh,
there's a winner.
Someone was able to gut it out
and come out on top and come over,
come out with all that dealing
with all that adversity.
And then you look down the
line like who did what?
And then even the guy who did
the worst and the tournament,
let's say all of a sudden
non tournament style,
they start racking up
the wins and it's like,
Oh wow,
you know,
look at that story.
That person's coming back from what we
consider to be a disaster and now their
Phoenix rising from the ashes.
It gives such an opportunity to uh,
to exempt,
to show human spirit,
to show overcoming adversity.
And it's an instant trade off.
I think it's a great idea for grappling.
Eddie Bravo had the
Eddie Bravo invitational,
the Ebi last week and it was a tournament
and it was really exciting to watch,
watch guys make it to the
finals and watch guys,
you know,
you see the brackets play out.
I think it's great for grappling.
What I worry about it
is with head injuries.
I worry about guys
fighting the first round,
getting their bell rang,
having some internal bleeding perhaps.
And then fighting in the final.
I don't,
I don't think that the medical,
um,
uh,
observation should be,
should be,
should be overlooked.
I think that's important.
But,
uh,
I really think tournaments,
we would help bring some
excitement back to him and May,
but then here's the other thing,
I think five minute rounds
are not long enough.
I think we do a 10 minute rounds,
at the very least.
I knew.
Agree.
I see you nodding your
head over there guys.
Let's not even talk about how the 10
point must system doesn't belong in MMA.
Not all terrible,
but,
uh,
and I understood why they use the 10
point because it's to try and keep people
honest.
All you can see that they scored the
round that there no one's sitting.
That's as it's been explained to me.
But uh,
well they just borrowed,
it doesn't box.
It doesn't need it.
You know,
he just,
I liked it.
And Japan where they just look okay.
And pancreas,
it used to be two judges
on the outside and the ref,
their judgements at the end,
if they decide all three
of them convene up,
he won.
I see,
I disagree with that using the ref
cause I think a referee should,
I think that's a very singular job.
And I think the referee's job
should be making sure that I can,
I can see,
I can see the argument.
I'm just saying how it used to be,
but even still,
no matter what the idea was.
And,
and back in pride,
it was,
you had your criteria.
Matt would sit ringside
with a piece of paper,
one name and then another name and a
line down the middle for each side.
And he would sit there and he would put
hash marks and each box and those hash
marks meant something along
those criteria that were,
uh,
that were important that he could look
back and it would help him remember how
this fight went.
Well,
Matt,
it's an excellent referee.
Oh well yeah.
Well,
and this is just same as a judge,
but uh,
so I agree with,
I'm more towards that side,
but even still now you see guys
just gaming a five minute round,
stifling doing this,
doing that,
and then petering off to the fucking,
the stool coming back out.
And just trying to run the same thing
or when two out of three and then they
walk out and look at me.
It's like,
well,
you didn't even really try
to kick that guy's ass.
Well at one have fun with that.
What do you think about standups?
Do you think the standup
should be a part of MMA?
Yes,
you do,
but that has to be with
the other thing with him.
Amazing.
He needs to be more attention to stalling.
If you're not trying to finish
your opponent and damage them,
take them out.
You're stolen.
What do you think about
if they do have rounds?
Like say if you go a 10 minute round,
at the end of 10 minutes,
you're,
you're on top of the guy.
Mount doom.
Yeah.
Start right back with the
mount on the second round.
That's an interesting concept.
But a,
I like standing in
backup on the feet again,
but why that gives us
striker a big advantage.
You need to be a well rounded fighter,
right?
But if you work so hard to
get a guy to the ground,
he didn't earn getting
back up to his feet.
Why should he be able to
get back up to his feet?
Well,
that's the whole concept of rounds
is the restart of the contest.
Right?
Restart of you getting
a chance to get back up.
That's true too.
Yeah.
So if he can survive the round,
what does that mean?
If,
if it is that dire to you,
that you cannot afford to have that guy
ever get back to his feet either by the
round ending or by him escaping or the
referee standing up for an activity.
Well,
one,
you're fucked as a fight or anyways,
you're,
you have a huge deficit.
Number two,
you better finish him,
right?
You better finish them.
That also goes to,
so,
hey,
if you're the greatest grappler submission
guy in the world and you have no
takedowns enjoy getting your ass kicked.
Well,
there's a few fighters that are really
good at holding guys down and I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
because I think it's important to know
that a guy can hold you down.
Like Ben aspirins.
My perfect example,
Ben Asterisk is such a good fucking
wrestler that he gets ahold of guys and he
puts them on their back
and they can't get back up.
And if that's the case,
like standing a guy giving a guy a free
shot to stand back up because Ben asked
her,
may or may not be as active
as you would like or it might,
but still the guy who was on the
bottom wants to get up but you can't.
Right.
But you know,
you've got 10 minutes to work.
I F I C and uh,
I think honestly with 10 minutes,
I don't think ask him wouldn't have as
many decisions as he does because we'll
ask her and has kept a lot
of people on their back.
I've seen him work a lot
too looking for submissions.
Punching.
He's not a power puncher would you say?
He's up til a puncher,
but one FC allows them to do
knees to the head on the ground.
That makes a big,
that's another thing I would change,
I think needs of the head soccer kicked,
stomped,
you know,
I'm all for all that.
But at the very least,
knees to the head change things and uh,
a lot,
especially even for the grappler.
Uh,
but with 10 minutes you want
to call Ben Aspirin boring.
I think in 10 minutes he's got finishes.
Yeah.
I think that,
uh,
a lot of guys would have finishes,
but the other thing that changes that
is when a ref is standing over the top
going,
action,
action.
Action.
Okay,
get up.
You're stalling.
Your cool.
You know,
when a guy is stalling,
you don't want a guy is not.
Yeah,
but I think a guy who's stalling,
if you can't get that guy off you,
fuck you.
Well that's a different fight then.
That's that settle
because the guy you are,
you're on the bottom.
You're still fighting.
No,
no,
I hear you that way.
But we're talking about prize fighting.
Right.
Entertainment.
Mm.
Okay.
If,
if,
if it's the fight that you're talking
about that's not for entertainment,
no one wants to pay to see that.
You know what that is?
That's catch wrestling in the 18 hundreds.
That's pro wrestling in the 19 hundreds
where three hours plus of guys trying to
get an advantage and can't because
they're so well versed of each other.
They're so tough.
They're so skilled.
One guy getting stuck on the bottom,
he can't get up.
There's no restarts,
there's no nothing.
There's no,
there it goes.
Let's see when that first fall comes,
but that died out.
It didn't work.
If you look at like say like what
they were doing with a lead Xc,
that's like the worst case example of
trying to make it an entertainment.
Sure,
sure,
and I'm not suggesting that
you just do it on the DC.
Do they used to make,
they used to Dan,
Dan people.
They would take seconds on the ground.
They stand you back up.
He stood up big country.
He was on top of our Lawsky inside control
working with Kamora or would you call
it double risk?
I've devoted like,
yes.
Now he,
I don't know if he was
ever going to get it,
but he was in an advantage.
His position,
he was working for a finish.
He should not have been stood up and he's
an expert in that particular style of
fighting.
He's in a submission next,
he's a ground guy and he
wasn't just laying on him.
He was trying to submit our Lawsky and uh,
you know,
of course with anything you need,
even as a sports sits now we need better
referees and we need better judges.
Yeah.
That stoppage.
Last week they reversed that.
Oh,
did they reversed it?
Yeah,
it's a no contest.
Even when Faber's down,
they're getting walloped on
his shoulder and it's like,
show me something.
One,
you couldn't see his thumbs up.
I got it.
On the second hand,
you can tell he's not getting
his ass kicked right now.
Let it go.
Let them go when a guy's turtling and
the guy was just hitting your gloves and
arms.
And then if I get stopped,
that is very frustrating.
It is this problem with that.
But I watched all these
fights back in the day.
I'd seen dudes getting
shellshocked on top,
just just artillery dropped
on him and surviving it.
Then reversing the fight.
Dude's all totally,
totally petered out and Brock Lesnar
changes and just kicking the shit out of
them.
Yeah,
it happens.
And Brock Lesnar and car when,
that's a good example too,
but no one wants to let
that happen anymore.
Well as too brutal.
Well,
we're not,
we're fighting.
We're not doing patty cake.
Well,
there's always that thing about trying
to make it more appealing to the
mainstream.
It will be better for everybody,
and yet it's not better for the
people that are actually doing it.
No,
it's definitely not better for someone
who gets stuck in a position and they
intelligently defend yourself.
Well,
guess what?
There's some positions where
willing guys wailing on you.
It's intelligent to just cover up.
Sure.
Remember a tank and a seven,
seven kept palm striking him and just
throwing all these shots and the seven
wasn't,
it wasn't palm striking because you're
not a punch just because he didn't want
to break his hand.
No gloves,
no wraps.
So he smack and a tank,
the tank,
he tries to get up,
but he can't.
Now,
one of these modern reps are
probably stopped that fight.
Oh,
you're not intelligent
that defending yourself.
He's not going to go out.
He's not getting his bell rung.
He's not getting the
shit kicked out of him.
He just can't get up right now.
Frank talked about,
Oh,
when a tank talked about it,
he said a hell nightmare.
I was getting molested by Freddie Mercury.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and tank tried to get up.
He was,
he was just getting controlled.
He couldn't get up at seven.
Didn't have the ability to
really finish him either.
Right.
So it is what it is.
That's what it is.
You know,
I needed to keep going,
but I don't think that should be stood up.
What about,
no,
not in that case cause cause
seven was incredibly active.
Right.
He was trying,
he just didn't really have the,
the,
the scalability yet.
And here's another one.
Ruan Pot's getting punched in the ribs
and then stopping it because he's just,
he's stuffing Elton.
Yeah.
Do you see him tapping?
No.
Do you see him saying I want out?
Yeah,
I didn't agree with and I know how much
he's getting punched in the fucking
ribs.
Did Adam get punched in the ribs?
They stopped that fight just to rescue
everybody from how boring it was.
Cause he was just on top of him
punching him in the same spot.
Everybody's like this.
We've seen it now.
Who Look at that Bruce.
So what?
It is bruised.
This is a bruise.
Very bad.
So sore tomorrow he's going
to have a black and blue spot.
Yes.
A real black and blues Paul.
Oh my God.
And I even turned yellow
and purple at some point.
It could very well turn
like orange Ygrene.
Oh God,
we can't allow that.
That's what I'm saying.
What if stand them up?
Yeah.
Or stop the fight all together.
That's not intelligent defense.
There's not enough.
There's certain guys
that fight in the UFC.
We got to go,
man,
who the fuck let you fight in the UFC?
Well they need a lot of fighters.
They have so many events,
so,
so many events.
They got to fill them up
and there's just too many.
Do you think there's too many?
Yes.
Yeah I do.
There are,
you know,
they have a plan for what they're trying
to accomplish and this is what they see
is the,
is the path to doing.
So,
you know what I think there should be,
I think should be an a
league and a B league.
I agree that there should
be a UFC and a strike force.
I agree.
If that fight should have one headliner
type dude or one main card type guy and
arrested just up and comers.
Yeah,
why not?
I mean,
and then those guys
will graduate to become,
you know,
well,
can you imagine if it,
you even even this,
what if,
what if they kept Strikeforce and UFC and
let's say Strikeforce went pride style
and UFC was the UFC and then they had
a super bowl match every year and each
year with switch one this year.
It's pride.
It's pride world rules
this year at UFC rules.
Oh God,
I can hear it now.
Oh.
But the difference in that if you
can't fight and one of the other,
if it is that dire to you as an athlete,
that you can only can,
you can only be successful in one arena.
You're just not that good.
Well,
you're not that well rounded.
Well for sure.
But I mean,
anything you can do on one you
can do in the other really well.
We did see big differences between of
guys fighting in the cage and got us
fighting in the ring
that had to do with it.
No,
you don't think cro cop was talking
about how big of a different it's,
it was elbows on the ground
was a big difference as well.
That definitely changes some things,
but no,
I don't think that was it.
So you think it's just the
lack of preparation pop?
I personally don't have a
perfect answer for that,
but I don't believe it.
It was that,
well,
obviously he did much better after that.
Yes.
He got better at figuring out of the
cage and the elbows on the ground and the
defense.
Yes.
So it's probably just a lack of the proper
preparation that maybe this is only a
few places.
Like if you,
if you really looked at
a young athletes today,
they want to compete in MMA.
Is there a dozen places in this country
that you could go and get a proper
education as far as like being a
real professional MMA fighters,
even a dozen.
I,
you know,
I can't say I've done all the research
to say conclusively one way or the other.
I know that AMC CSW one of the best,
uh,
AMCs I mean,
Matt Hume is about as knowledgeable
as anybody has ever lived well,
and looks at me and Matt human,
Eric Paulson or kind of cut from the
same cloth and that their lineage comes
down from Karl Gotch,
from the shoot,
from a Siama and finicky and you know,
well rounded,
full meal deal dues.
They could do everything.
Yup.
And,
uh,
you know,
so there's that.
But,
uh,
I,
I'm,
I mean,
I don't know.
I imagine Greg Jackson's could
probably make you a con for us.
A hobby.
Yeah.
Maybe.
I mean,
I,
I've never trained her to these people.
I knew that I was very,
when I moved from when I moved from
maths gym to go train somewhere else,
it was really hard for me to find,
there wasn't very many people back then
and I felt like I could go there and
learn where I wouldn't be the one
dictating all the training all the time.
I would be somewhere where I
could learn and be trained.
What made you decide to go from Seattle
and then live in southern California?
How come you don't stay up
there and train with Matt?
Uh,
at the time it just
wasn't really feasible.
I didn't have the sparring partners and
Matt wasn't really around that much,
so I was ending up having to do a lot of
my own training because he was going to
pride to judge.
He had a lot of stuff on his plate.
And,
uh,
and,
and especially like I said,
I had no sparring partners.
I had nothing.
Uh,
I was re,
sandy was my main dude and we would do
a lot of training together every night,
somewhat Jeff months in.
But a lot of time I ended up teaching
Jeff and even teaching Reese and they were
great guys and I learned a lot from,
they were very,
very,
very helpful,
but I didn't have sparring
partners and then I just thought,
well,
this isn't the place to be.
Seattle is my barn on favorite place in
the U S and one of my favorite place in
the whole world,
and then she was an amazing city.
Do you like clouds?
I like clouds.
I like Flan.
Russian.
I'm into suppression
and heroin altogether.
Coffee?
Yup.
Stinky post lost.
Hey,
what'd you come up with that?
Yeah.
What the hell?
Why?
Why do you have Megan?
Seattle's think he puts
his stories are what?
Yeah.
What are you talking about?
They just never clean it.
They're just all in bed sleeping,
crying and shit.
That's not true at all.
No Way.
First of all,
they don't clean your pussy.
Yeah.
Then the self cleaning org,
they have a lot of probiotic stuff up
there like yogurts and Kim cheese that
they made from the farmer's market there.
They're good.
It's actually important for women and
not do that like douchey and stuff that's
like super bad for you.
It not amazing these to promote
that all the time girls stuff,
they had to do it.
My mom did it all the time.
She,
you know this because when I was a kid,
when I was a kid,
I used,
what's that vacuum noise
opened up the Hoover dam gates of hell.
When I was a kid I saw one of those empty
bottles in the trashcan and I used it
to drink koolaid out if cause I thought
it was a cool bottle cause I had that's
cool straw thing.
I believe my mom,
she never told me what it
was until like years later.
And then when he found out he
thought it was even cooler.
Yeah.
Your mom was what?
You were walking around the house
just sucking on your mom's douchebag.
I swear to God,
she was like,
go ahead
Brian.
Play outside.
Yeah.
See those power lines.
Go climb them.
Have here,
have this lead paint sandwich right now.
But,
uh,
it's true story,
you know,
all that Douche ing and now all
that teaching has now reversed.
It's come full,
full,
full frontal.
And where people wear it now with like
all the dragons and fucking flirting lees
and Voluma or on their shirts,
how's a Duchenne?
Oh,
I get it.
Anyways,
we'll do she sternal Douche.
But,
uh,
you know,
I,
I wanted to go somewhere where one,
I knew there would be no,
uh,
issues and trying to find
people to work out with.
And so cal is still,
in my opinion,
the Mecca of MMA and
Generika and then a big guys.
Right?
And for a guy like you,
it's important to have history
guys to train with heavy guys,
quality guys,
you need,
you need a whole lot of,
uh,
different kinds of guys.
Yeah.
You need to shave guys
that don't show y'all like,
sure,
why not.
But for you,
it's really is important to have heavy,
good guys,
right?
Like for a guy like you,
like say if you're working out with a
bunch of like really good middleweights
sounded good enough,
right?
Uh,
depends on what I'm trying to work on.
If I'm just going against the guide,
it's just working on passing somebody's
guard or something like that.
Sure,
fine.
And we're just catching a leg fine.
But if I need to have someone to push me,
I need someone to be able
to match me with strength,
uh,
weight,
all that kind of stuff.
And then Eric was down here
also everything else that
you could jump off from
fighting as an entertainment,
uh,
a commodity and to anything
else acting this way,
you keep bringing that up.
Is that what you're trying to do
now is I have a smart dude like you,
you think about your athletic career,
you know,
you can't do this forever.
Everybody's athletic window is a
very small portion of their life.
It's important,
but you need to not just
be the best athlete.
You need to grow as a person
and you need to be able to,
it's not about setting up plan B,
it's about evolving as a person.
That's about opening new doors and doing
new things and growing and having new
opportunities.
And so I've been acting,
uh,
I've done commentary.
I'm doing commentary on new Japan
pro wrestling on access right now.
And that's not new to me.
I've done,
I've never done progressing commentary,
but I've done tons of fight commentary.
I did commentary for pride or did
commentary for some other events from
pancreas.
And uh,
it was like,
cool,
I can do this and that's no problem.
Even though he kept hitting me up.
Well,
why don't you do UFC events?
Why don't you do this one?
You're like,
well no one,
they're not hiring me.
So that's why I'm not
doing commentary there.
And then I got the Steven
Seagal movie coming out,
absolution.
It should be out relatively
soon to spar with Steven Seagal.
And I did not have to sparse teams.
A goal on my balls are perfectly intact.
I didn't have any fight scenes with him.
I just scenes with him
acting scenes and not really,
uh,
he,
he was in a scene where
I'm in the background.
I just end up getting
into a fight with him,
with his sidekick guy.
Anyways,
so I give that dude his hero moment,
a by run man who did a great job.
Uh,
and I've got another movie that should
be coming out sometime this year called
chuck Hank and the San Diego twins.
It's an indie film.
It's fucking completely insane.
So how do you balance that between
training or you like leaning more towards
that area now?
You haven't fought since
the Travis Brown fight,
right?
Last year,
2014 December.
Do you have anything on your,
on your plate right now?
I'm hoping I at some point to get a
word on whether or not I'm fighting Roy
Nelson because we,
it was brought up,
someone brought up the idea of,
uh,
Roy and me doing metamorris.
Yeah,
that's what I've kind of had to,
it was like,
oh,
okay.
Really?
And then Roy said,
Nah,
that sounds cool,
but we fight first,
pays better.
And how I had,
well,
if you're willing,
I'm willing.
And he said,
good,
let's make it happen.
I said,
well,
I guess that's that.
If we say we're going to,
we're willing to fight and
we're ready to step up and go,
then you know what's legit.
And have there been any conversations
with Joe Silva or the highly,
I imagine my manager's
the one with all of that,
but I'll show you.
You have your manager was informed
of all this stuff and hey,
go deal with that.
Yeah,
but I gotta Act pretty much.
I got,
I gotta hit acting class.
You wouldn't be opposed to doing
a metamorris with him though?
No,
I'm not opposed to doing
a metamorris with anybody.
I think.
I don't think I'll ever get a chance to
finish the rubber match with Nogueira.
Uh,
but I could at least probably get
him on the mat and Metamorris.
Do you think so?
I think so.
I mean,
I don't see why he wouldn't want to do
it and why people wouldn't want to see
that.
But I've already got a brain.
You cyborg coming up.
Uh,
May 9th.
That's a more interesting,
that's very interesting.
Especially after you just
submit a dean lister.
That's very huge dude.
Submitting Dean lister is
a gigantic accomplishment.
It hadn't been done in 16 years.
That's amazing that since the Clinton
administration had anybody tap dean lister
and the way you got them,
would that choke?
I mean that's,
that is some old school shit that's,
that's high school wrestling.
Yeah.
And with wrestling shoes on and the old
school spandex stuff sexy spend x man,
pull up the photo of Josh Barnett.
No.
Would you,
did you wear this Josh Bartlett
and he's in Baltimore eyes less.
You eat less.
You'd like your panties to catch fire,
your vagina's for a fury of hormones.
Did you wear this like as a a
like an homage to pro wrestling?
Absolutely is an homage to my trainers.
Uh,
Billy Robinson,
Karl Gotch,
uh,
and and also to Eric cause that's
from his roots and Matt Hume.
But uh,
from my training,
my roots,
my heritage,
my catch wrestling training and to Antonio
and Oakey who was one of my trainers
for professional wrestling.
So I had the towel around my neck,
the robe,
even the way I took the
robe off and there was all,
all of that.
The black boots,
it's all black.
It's all in Oman.
And respect
to my,
my catch wrestling roots and my trainers.
Well it's,
I think it's important to highlight those
roots to for the just the lineage of
MMA because a lot of folks that are on
the outside are not aware that there were
several different branches
of submission fighting,
you know,
not just judo,
not just Jujitsu notches.
Sambo catch wrestling had some really
legit submissions that are still used
today and a lot of really great grapplers
but catch wrestling eventually sort of
morphed into professional wrestling
and a lot of folks are not aware of the
original aspect of catch wrestling,
which we're talking about these three
hour matches and guys that would go to,
they would do carnival matches where they
would go roll into town and wrestling.
You who owned a big
old carnival in Brazil,
who?
The head of the Gracie family at the time.
Good style.
Really.
He owned a carnival and he
had professional wrestling
catch wrestling matches at
his carnival who should happen to
come and perform in one of these catch
wrestling matches.
But the account coma Mitsui [inaudible],
he stayed in Brazil.
Carlos Gracie started training
under him in judo and catch,
uh,
is where now all of a sudden
you have Gracie Jujitsu.
So it's sort of branched off from
a bunch of different sources,
not just from judo but don't catch
wrestling as well because my,
I had been traveling the world competing
and catch matches and all that.
Kimora competed in catch matches as well.
So even though the Americana arm lock
came from American wrestlers catch,
they allude to leave ray background
comes from catch a tattoo,
a Ukulele,
these hot them,
he was a catch wrestler.
He was trained to do show matches,
but at the same time he trained,
even back then,
even if you did works,
you trained as a shooter,
you trained to do that shit for real.
Look at this beautiful
outfit and a mother Fucker,
uh,
comes out,
right.
The robe on.
This is so old school view,
look at this to do this.
And metamorris he almost had to feel like
you're kind of wearing like a costume.
Yeah,
I knew that people would be unfamiliar.
They wouldn't understand it,
but people did understand it though.
A lot of people in the underground,
especially with like,
no,
those socks are for,
uh,
in reference to all my
time spent in Japan.
And uh,
you know,
the people I've trained over there.
Uh,
but uh,
they uh,
uh,
you know,
they,
they've paid laughed when I said
I'm just going to wear shoes.
They're like,
oh my God,
you're going to wear
choosing as dean lister.
Oh,
you're Stan.
I don't think you should do this.
Or as a leg lock specialist,
right.
To provide a lot of extra traction
for holding all this stuff about,
oh,
I can't believe we're going to work.
Are you still going to do up until the
day of the event you're really going to
wear shoes?
Yes.
I go out there.
I tap him.
Although his shoes that
gave him such an advantage.
Oh,
I'll fuck.
Are you kidding me now?
The are not my detriment
there.
My disadvantage.
Oh,
and then it was,
you weighed so much more than dean.
Dean was like two 40.
Now I don't,
I don't know.
I was like two 55,
so I had 15 pounds on him.
I hug.
I gave Dina hug the day of the weigh
ins while we didn't actually weigh in,
but I gave him a hug and my fingers.
I had to go catch fingers and roll my
grip into it to actually get all the way
around us.
It was so fucking thick.
He's a big fucker thick and veiny purple.
Whoa.
Slow down.
You want to help me on
my throbbing ground game?
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
That what they bought it these days.
Uh,
D was a big massive guy
when he fought Babaloo.
I was really shocked that he was like
allowing almost Bob Ballou to lock up
Darcy's on them like,
like Baba lose a really
good submission guy.
He is excellent and he's just so
smiley at getting out all that stuff.
I was shocked.
I was shocked that he was allowing that,
but it also looked like he didn't
have the gas to go a full 20 like,
you know,
Bob a loo at the end of the match
was in way better shape and dean was,
I agreed.
Herring around all that muscle,
all that mass that he carry.
Well,
you're a bigger guy.
Like he might be two 40 but a lot
of that is Mexican supplements.
There's a big difference between
your two 40 and his two fort.
I'm saying like,
no,
I mean I think avocado,
a hot sauce,
you know that stuff has done wonders.
Fine.
Speaking of different supplements,
sir,
but I mean the green sauce,
he's so skilled and talented too.
I mean it's not just all the extra muscle.
He was strong as shit when I wrestled
him and apparently his guys and him,
Dean said he wrestled a lot of big dudes.
They wrestled against guys for pressure
from top and it's just that I was able
to apply it that much better.
Did you think that you are going to
be able to catch him with that choke?
Was that something specifically
that you had saw before?
Did you game plan?
Well,
yeah.
Well Rica Rodriguez was the
last guy to tap him for that.
And how would it happen with Same Cho?
Exactly.
You know who taught Rico the choked,
by the way?
Eric Paulson,
I'll fucking boxing
works in Redondo beach.
Yes,
absolutely.
Yeah.
God Damn.
You know,
I remember first hearing about,
uh,
catch wrestling.
Was it frank gotch?
Was he the one that would drop?
No.
Who was the guy that would drop down?
It was a sh a small dude.
What the fuck was his name?
God dammit.
I'm so catch wrestler.
Was that who the guy
was that used to drop a,
he used to do like hangman's drops.
So that is farmer burns
from Martin's farmer.
Burns' farmer bro is
framed in there somewhere.
It's farmer.
Yeah.
He can hang himself and not break
his neck is there's pictures of it.
Look up,
look up farmer Burns'
catch wrestling image.
See if you find an image of this
guy fucking hanging himself.
It's morbid.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Look at that fucking picture.
The guy hung himself.
That's how strong his fucking neck was.
He would hang his whole probably really
good for decompression of the spine.
I actually do a thing in my house where
I probably jerking off at the same,
oh,
I wear a wet suit.
There's a black dildo.
I have this,
um,
this thing that I bought
a spinal decompression set
up that hangs from a door.
You put it on the door
like a bathroom door.
It's like at this bolt screws and place,
it has like an arm and
then you ratchet it,
like click,
click and it like decompress your spine.
It's like a nice little stretch,
right?
This motherfucker,
David,
David Carradine did too.
I don't think that the same.
I think what he did was different.
How does that not just rip
your door off the hill?
Cause you're not really putting
your whole weight on it.
You're sitting down.
First of all,
you do it in a chair.
Like say this thing,
it's velcroed into your head here.
Like,
um,
I know what you're talking about.
You know what I'm talking about.
And you do,
you know what you're talking about.
And it's,
uh,
I think if you can use it properly,
it,
it's a good,
it's a good thing.
Having the spinal
decompression is important.
Uh,
but what he was doing was not,
no.
And that's why the fuck was insane.
And uh,
you know,
catch,
catch wrestlers trained fucking
hardest shit does Brian.
No,
that's not it changed.
Fuck.
See this.
Oh Wow.
So this thing,
yeah,
that's crazy.
That's,
that's exactly what it is.
His face looks just like
that when he does it too.
It's stretches your neck a little bit
cracked around your job's not what it is.
It's more like a bra,
like a Bra.
Oh God.
I've pissed off so many
women when I've said,
oh,
hey,
whatever,
uh,
blah,
blah.
Don't forget your training bra training.
Training,
like training newsletters.
Yeah,
no,
I didn't mean,
yeah,
you can't say that.
I just get the evil.
Look I didn't like,
I don't mean like you
have new tits meant Bra.
When you train,
what do they call one
of those sports bras?
Sports Bra.
Now you've got training Bra.
You gotta be real.
It is a bra that you train in.
That's not how they look.
Not a training bra.
It's a very different animal.
It will get you all kinds of heat
can get upset if training underwear.
What have you seen?
I love,
you said get your go eat a training bra.
He's like,
what?
Yeah,
but then you told the guy,
go pick up your training cup.
Oh my Dick's growing.
I get to used to wearing a cup.
You need support and all the right places.
You know,
this is a very random question that
was very specific or I should say,
what do you think about a tie steel
cups for grappling competition.
So they're getting outlawed and a lot
of grappling competitions because they
provide that extra leverage.
They're like a fulcrum point,
like a leverage point.
Okay Lynn.
And then everybody's got a free ball,
three ball.
You know,
you just gotta use that Third Hook
wrap your Dyngus around there.
You see we bring Brian on.
These podcasts are,
wouldn't goes in the fucking,
well,
here's the,
here's the thing,
here's the no,
I mean I'm here.
I'm barely 11 and a half,
so I wouldn't have,
I don't,
I usually don't train with a cup.
You don't know because my
legs are so big that it's,
it rubs with bruising in the,
in the inside of my thighs.
I personally,
I have a thing I like to call combat
cock where everything just pulls it zen.
Yeah.
Do you remember those guys knows better
than to get fucking hanging out there.
Hey,
how you doing?
What's up?
High?
Five is educated.
My Dick is smart.
Just like the Shaolin Monks.
I've known guys have
lost a ball from that.
Ah,
not me.
Yeah.
Well there's Brian Foster's.
I was,
it was,
it was my father's TFC.
Oh,
is in training and he got kicked
in the balls and last one.
It was balls.
Yeah.
Did you ever find it Dick?
Just stupid Dick.
Terrible decisions.
What's going on?
Yeah.
His Dick is always like,
what are you doing?
Have you seen where his dick as Ben?
Can you imagine it?
Does Dick's a lot?
Need to be alive?
Yes,
I have.
I've seen like pictures.
Oh,
you've been in the room?
Oh fuck.
You know what?
I'm after he over,
he just want to take like a whole,
like a bottle of paint.
Then I'd be like,
you need to just dip in this real quick.
Did you guys see that thing?
There was a fucking guy who is a scientist
for Monsanto and was trying to say
that,
pull it off of my,
um,
my youtube,
uh,
my,
rather and my Twitter feed.
This is hilarious.
I retweeted it.
This,
this fucking Monsanto scientist
was trying to say that,
um,
this pesticide was totally safe to drink.
Just stuff that's in roundup and then
you could drink it and nothing that the
toys or whatever.
So there's a video of him.
Second Idiot.
And so he's talking to this dot.
This,
uh,
this journalist and the
journalist who's a really,
you,
you would drink it.
He goes,
sure,
I would drink it.
He goes,
okay,
we're going to get your glass.
And you drank it.
Like,
watch this.
Gmo Advocates as Montana,
Monsanto or herbicide is safe to drink.
It's behind too many products.
The Canadians might know it.
Its roundup weed killer is that,
has glyphosate is a chemical,
that's it.
Glyophosphate quite faucet.
Watch this shit.
Deformities in children
growing into countries,
agricultural region.
Monsanto has denied any wrongdoing and
that the product is safe and that's where
Dr. Patrick Moore comes in and Monsanto
lobbyists sat down with French cable
channels can now plus more said you
could drink an entire quarter of this
product.
Her ears sports drink a whole
quarter of it and it won't hurt you.
It's you want to drink some?
We have some here.
I'd be happy to actually,
no,
not really,
but not really.
I know me.
That's when the interviewer asked more
to put his money where his mouth was and
drink the weed killer.
Okay.
Then it's finished.
Then the interview is finished and
say this is a good way to sell thing.
Yeah.
Complete Chirp.
Why did this complete check?
Did you order something?
Apparently it was a complete
jerk and franchise canard.
Is this the one that
was on my Twitter feed?
Hey,
maybe I watched more
than one version of this,
but the conversation lasted a
little longer than that as fucking,
that appears to be a lying piece of shit.
Yeah,
an amazing,
and he was like,
I would drink it.
Okay.
You want to drink it?
No,
you're a complete jerk
completers Starmie call.
Nah,
that guy's a doctor.
How fucking stupid can you be when you,
you go to school,
you're a doctor,
you get a degree
and then you're smart enough
where you get hired by Monsanto.
You're smart enough where
you do interviews and you
expect it to be an expert
but you're so fucking stupid.
You say something like,
oh you could drink it.
I would drink it.
He would drink it.
We have something stupid or do you think
he's just being a piece of shit and
trying to lie for Monsanto?
I think both.
Did they go into it and go like we broke
down the chemicals in this [inaudible]
actually be safe.
Like did they expand that at all?
Because a lot of those things like
the real issue is prolonged exposure.
Like I know a dude who has bone cancer
and he got bone cancer because his family
lived near a golf course and the golf
course used a lot of pesticides and
infected the well water and all the kids
in the neighborhood guide cancer too.
Like his next door neighbor got cancer,
has the duty lived across the street,
got cancer.
So important to keep
that grass nice and lush.
Right?
I don't think they knew.
I think there's a lot of carcinogen.
I'll give him that and that back in
the day they didn't understand how
potentially hazardous uh,
longterm effects versus
short term could be.
Even though they didn't really know how
bad cigarettes were entirely at a point.
But then it came a point
that they did know,
I mean cigarettes still blow me away.
Yeah.
Why do you add the shit in
all the poisons and stuff?
It's okay.
You're,
you're,
you're inhaling smoke,
which is,
we all know is bad.
You can die from smoke inhalation.
It's carcinogens or in their car.
Fine,
we got it.
Do you have to add all the
other crap that's in it?
They had all of our Schick
and all this garbage.
Like just to get you more,
why don't you just just give him the
fucking leaf to be a weed or be it fucking
tobacco.
Just let him smoke it.
Let them know what's going to happen.
But you don't have to help them.
You don't have to fuck and add rat poison,
try American spirits and compare
it to like a Marlboro light.
I don't huge difference in
the taste and everything,
but yeah,
it's,
they shouldn't do it,
but okay.
So kind of playing to us.
So you say the American spirit is,
tastes like shit in the
alarm rose taste better.
American spirits lasts forever.
Yeah.
I mean,
you can have one cigarette,
it takes like 15 minutes
and sure have like two.
Uh,
it,
it's,
it's a harsher thing.
You wake up the next day,
you're like,
oh,
like spitting up goobers and like,
it's really bad for you feeling,
uh,
bodywise where Marlboro.
Like you could smoke a whole pack.
I mean,
I've known,
I mean one that should usually smells
good around it does smell good too.
They don't seem to be.
Yeah.
Well Bertrand Russell didn't live to be
like fucking 90 something and he smoked
cigarettes every day or
smoked a high every day
you'll find people anywhere,
uh,
willing to for the right amount of
money to just fucking railroad humanity.
Hey,
just,
we'll do it.
I mean,
what about all these climate change?
Fucking asshole climate change deniers.
Yeah,
so find out where they're getting paid.
This is so funny is there's actually you
can go online and find all the senators
and all the congressmen that
are all climate change deniers.
You can find them all.
They,
they've listed all their names.
Well it's not just that.
How about the,
the different doctors that are testifying
against marijuana and you find out
being paid by pharmaceutical
companies.
This time and time again,
experts had been co opted by money but
when you see it so clear that like this
fucking guy,
you could drink a whole quarter
of it and you'd be fine.
Okay.
You want to drink it when you do,
you're a complete jerk.
I wouldn't drink a whole
court of fucking orange.
Yeah,
and they say that's safe.
Right.
Which I,
I don't know but I'm not going
to drink a quarter of it.
Fuck that.
If he did,
you would want to throw up.
I'm sure you would.
I mean court of,
first of all it's a powder.
You can really drove it quicker.
You,
you could pour a quart you to
amend the metal amount of liquid,
you would have to have to drink a quart
of Splenda or how about just a court of
a quart of water with a appropriately
dissolved solid of Splenda within it?
I'll do it w
it would only help him.
Yeah,
I know.
This is what it all,
because look,
if you've survived all the horrible
encounters you've had in your life up to
this point,
Brian,
that what's that going to do?
Right?
I mean,
you'd probably get a helpless,
right.
Dead in the eyes and kill,
kill the aids.
Fuck off.
You know?
Yeah.
It's going to kill the
aids inside of her body.
She's fucking,
I can't deal with this.
This is one,
one level too far.
Yeah.
I wonder if there's gonna come a time
in our future where these kind of guys,
these,
these guys were obviously bought
and paid just don't exist anymore.
How do you do that though?
You have to make people accountable
and we don't want to seem to do that.
And then the people you would
expect would make them accountable.
Right?
These are the,
these checks and balances
that get put together too.
Well,
this is to police that and this is,
they are all fucked up,
right?
I mean,
how do you let the banks
just rob you blind?
You know,
there's that whole library scandal where
they're just fudge and fixing numbers
and,
and they go to chase and they go,
well,
we're gonna,
we're gonna find you.
12 billion chased makes 45 billion a year.
It doesn't fucking matter.
You know what they did in Vietnam was
they went and they grabbed all the people
that all the bankers and all that,
all the officials that fucked everybody
over with in terms of the banking system
and they stuck him life
in prison and killed them.
Now you have one extreme to the other.
But nonetheless,
I mean,
what does,
what does worse?
Well,
yeah,
they're mean.
There's been many bankers that have
been caught that are doing things like
they're laundering money for drug cartels.
And that was one of the big ones.
It was recently exposed that these guys
were laundering money for Mexican drug
cartels and they just got a big fat fine.
You know,
I mean we,
meanwhile,
if it was you,
like if Brian was busted
laundering money for drug,
you'd be in jail for the
rest of your fucking life.
100%.
They take all of his fucking dryers and,
and uh,
all this all is whirlpools.
They'd get it.
Cause you know,
he laundering,
he would really launder it.
I know.
It's like I can do that.
He'd have an iron and ironing
board and turn it to super,
I could get
more money out of super.
Are you trying to say that
Brian is a child who's hockey?
I'm not exactly sure what
you're trying to say,
man.
I just like fucking with him
because he's here and he never,
every time I've been on your podcast,
Brian's off in the corner doing,
I don't even know.
I don't want to know
why right next to you.
So you can't hide anymore.
And,
and uh,
last time I saw him it was at our Buddy
Ryan's a or was it at the laugh factory
comedy stores?
Where was at the comedy store.
But yeah.
So I'm always like,
why don't you ever fucking,
you know me.
Why don't you hang out?
Yeah.
Why don't you come in,
hang out,
say something.
Cause he's nervous around
you because you're a man.
I am a man.
I made the kind of pheromones
it make other men will.
They were kind of,
man,
I need you to help me with my ground
game and my ground game is hopscotch.
So Oh easily.
We'll go from that to uh,
the fucking rubber band.
Jump Rope and uh,
we'll do foursquare after that.
Right?
I got all the kids games down.
Do you?
Oh yeah.
How do you,
how am I supposed to meet anybody in this,
this terrible world?
I mean,
come online dating.
You don't mind game.
I go out to the foursquare courts gaming
to find better words when you find the
athletes.
This fucking was done.
Do you want to do $5?
Just listen.
I've just listened to a lot of,
uh,
just listen to a lot of
Jethro Tull Aqualung,
you know,
or you want to do five minutes.
Do you ever want to do standup comedy?
Right.
Do,
and here's why.
It terrifies me,
Joe and Brian,
that terrifies me that you're
so raw and exposed up there.
And I'm not,
when I go and I fight,
I can fight for myself.
I can do it all.
You know,
my,
my success is measured upon my end.
You know,
did I get my hand raised in
and not getting my hand raised?
When you go out on that stage,
people are okay,
make me laugh fucker.
Right.
You're supposed to be funny,
aren't you?
So alright,
here I am.
Or they're like this.
I don't give a shit.
I'm talking to Brian or having a drink,
whatever,
some fucking noise off to my left.
I got to be interesting.
I got to do something that's
going to draw their attention.
And once I've drawn it,
I need to keep it.
Okay,
you got me.
What,
why should I pay attention?
And so I,
there's this necessity to,
to,
to be able to get a response for them,
which I understand from
professional wrestling because
I've been out in the ring
and I,
I listen to the crowd and I see
what works and what doesn't work.
And so I have an understanding.
I feel,
uh,
and from being around yourself and other,
you know,
I've,
I've not like a talk about it a lot,
but I've hung out with
quite a few comedians,
you know,
been there backstage for their shows
and we're fucking around warming up and
doing all this stuff and it's,
but I look at it and I go,
this is not just cracking
jokes and making people laugh,
and it is okay to bomb
because you're going to,
you're always going to fail.
But it's just such a raw
personal to a degree,
to me it's just for ripening.
Utterly frightening.
Yeah.
You should definitely do it then.
Do it tonight.
It's not that hard.
No,
don't do,
don't listen to him.
If you're going to do it,
you should plan it out.
I should definitely think about
it and write some stuff down.
I listen
to,
to things that you've said before about
being a comedian from documentary stuff
and things that I've seen of you.
And I have a thing in here,
in my notebook all on my phone.
Nothing but bits.
So you've thought about,
oh yeah,
no,
no.
I think about it.
I want you to do it.
Go to an open mic night.
Don't do it at a regular show.
He's trying to get you
to do one of his shows.
Don't
do it.
No,
you should go to a regular open mic night.
Like whether at the comedy store,
wherever you know,
just to five minutes or whatever they get.
What did they give you?
Three minutes,
two minutes.
Or you can do them in one minute and
killed Tony and we can help you out.
Don't do it now.
I don't know about that.
And you know,
they'll put it on the internet.
Sometimes.
I'll be honest,
Joe,
the shit that wants that I want to say
probably not good for the rest of what
I'm trying to accomplish.
Nah,
I disagree.
I don't know.
In what way?
How would it hurt you?
I,
I just really dark,
weird,
fucked up shit comes out of my mouth.
Look like,
would you give me an example?
Nope.
No.
Okay.
Ah,
so I did this thing before
MMA roasted was anything,
right?
They wanted to do.
They want to shoot a sizzle,
send it off to spike.
They wanted to make a show,
an actual show,
you do a panel and all this stuff.
So,
um,
uh,
Adam and uh,
oh my God,
why am I forgetting
everybody's name right now?
God dammit.
T rex.
So t rex hits me up and goes,
come on out,
come out and do this thing.
All right.
Uh,
what is it?
Okay,
I'll come sit around and you guys are
gonna probably try and talk shit to me and
talking about my past and fuck with
me and say steroids and whatever,
but I don't give a fuck.
So I come out and they
have this green rooms,
this green screen thing set up in this
deal and Adam does a monologue spots and
then he does,
he gets to the panel where we talk about
whatever's going on in MMA and we can,
we can fucking step off in any
direction we want and have fun.
And then he'll do a one on one where he,
in the,
whoever the guest is of the week,
we'll,
we'll sit there and Adam's just basically
kind of fuck with you the whole time.
So I come in,
I sit down on this panel thing
and they're filming all of this.
So it's t rex is to my left me this
female comedian who I don't really know an
Adam.
And then we just sit there and we start
talking and I just start saying shit.
One,
the female comedian immediately
gets really upset when we
t-rex,
can't stop laughing,
neither can add them.
And then I keep picking on fucking t rex
the whole time about his clothing line
at every,
at every point available.
Then we go and we do the,
the,
the sit down with me and Adam
and then I take it from him.
And then I was just start making them
laugh and saying really weird shit and
completely throwing them for a loop.
And I just said to him,
at the end of the day,
I go,
that was a lot of fun.
This is never seen the light of day,
right?
No,
not always.
Good.
Well,
what were you saying?
Nah,
I don't want to talk about,
no,
it was funny.
I think,
well,
they thought it was funny at the time.
I thought it was funny,
but,
but I've said a lot of fucked up things.
You can say those things
because they're your,
there's an excepted
aspect that you are Joe Rogan,
the comedian.
You are Joe Rogan talks about DMT,
talks about marijuana and aliens and
all kinds of stuff and we accept that.
And you're,
you're,
you're an established person within the,
the fan base that you have.
And you're a known commodity for those
that are only casual Joe Rogan knowers
from,
uh,
news radio.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
uh,
the fucking,
the factor.
Well that,
but even before that,
uh,
the,
the radio,
the Sitcom you did news radio,
news,
radio,
yeah,
fear factor.
All of these other
things where people will,
we'll see,
hey,
Joe Rogan,
he's a comedian.
Maybe we've seen some of his standup,
maybe not,
but we know him as a
personality on television,
so you know,
I'm fucking around.
Whereas with you,
they might just think you're a snob and
I'm an athlete and I'm supposed to be
this and I'm supposed to be bad.
And so if I make off color jokes that are,
it's like,
oh,
that's too far,
but whatever.
When you retired from fighting,
how many more years?
How old are you now?
36 37 37.
How many more years do you
think you'll be competing?
Uh,
till I'm done now.
See that's going on til I'm done.
Because
like I said before about
that athletic window.
So Joe Rogan has a,
you know,
this whole part of his
whole career to stand up,
very standup oriented and specific.
And then boom,
he moves into a movies and then he,
maybe he goes from there into politics.
I mean,
the thing is that you can enter
any kind of line you want,
but those things are not
incumbent on your physicality.
What they are is it's your mind.
It's your ability to fighting physicality.
Anything athletic wise,
you have so long to do it.
And that's it.
When that opportunity has passed,
you cannot do it anymore.
Now maybe you know,
you could say,
okay,
well Joe went for the US national
team for taekwondo to go to,
to win that and then go where in the
world team trials and go to the Olympics.
Going to the Olympics is a,
is a short opportunity in life.
Once you get past that point where
you can be competitive at that,
that doesn't mean you
can't do taekwondo anymore.
It wouldn't mean that you
couldn't do other tournaments,
but trying to be the Olympic
champion and taekwondo,
I was like,
wow,
that was gone.
That opportunity has passed me.
For me,
we're now opportunity to,
for me to be a successful
high level fighter is gone.
It's gone.
It's just,
that's it.
You just have to personally assess
when you feel like your body is not
performing the way you expect it to.
Exactly.
But right now you're cool with it
right now.
I'm cool right now.
I know I can do a lot better than
last fight for sure.
Why did you decide take so much time off
between your last fight and now?
I wasn't into my last fight and be honest,
I didn't care.
I just,
I wasn't up for it.
I trained and I got to a
point where I'm just like,
I'm over this.
You're over it.
Who are in town?
Who is this guy?
I mean Travis Brown.
Really?
Yeah,
but it's just like,
okay,
if I beat him,
what does that do?
Well,
he's a top five fighter,
so what?
Then I get to not fight another guy and
fight another guy and fight another guy
until it's like,
well,
where,
where am I going with this?
I'm in the grind and I'm trying to,
I'm not going to climb this fucking ladder
to prove that I deserve to fight for
a title.
I can fight for a title,
I guess anyone in any league,
anywhere,
anytime.
Fucking I'm a championship
world champion level guy.
I don't need to prove that I belong here.
I've fought Travis Browne's all my career.
They just had a different name
at a different point in life.
They had the same type of skillset.
They're basically the same guy.
There'll be another Travis Browne when
Travis Browne is done being Travis
Browne.
So what do you try to say that you,
the only thing that would get
you up is a fight for a title.
Not necessarily,
but just I got to fight
when it makes sense to me.
I got to fight when
I'm motivated to do so.
I don't,
I'm not looking to try and say,
all right,
throw me in there with all these other
fucking goof balls and let us just beat
each other's heads in until we
try to prove that we belong here.
Does that just signify,
look at the final chapter of
your athletic career then?
Because if like a guy like Travis Browne,
if you were coming up,
you would relish the opportunity
to fight a top five guy.
Sure.
So is it because you
just very established?
He'd been around a long time?
I've learned that I don't need to,
I don't need to prove myself in that way.
When I,
when I go to,
I don't,
I,
I've been a top 10
fighter for over a decade.
I've been top five for over
a decade most of the time.
So whether or not someone
ranks me wherever they rank me,
it doesn't really matter.
I can step in there and do the job.
And this next fight might be against Roy,
which is fine,
but if then the next fight is we want
you to fight cane or Buddhism or whoever,
like let's go,
I'm fucking ready to do it.
But did you feel that
when you fought Frank Mir?
Yes.
When I fought Frank Mir,
I was fucking pumped because
for one I've been told,
oh,
that I'd hear it.
All these people we think it's going
to be deal is because he's such a tough
fight.
And,
and Frank Mir is,
he's the piece of the best submission guy.
And or back when I was in the UFC,
uh,
and frank was just coming up,
they're like,
oh,
this guy's the future.
He's the best.
He's going to be the greatest.
And always hearing all this stuff about
how Frank Mir is my equal or better.
And I'm just like,
this shit is over with.
This is not,
I'm going to show you the
difference between us,
between him and me.
So you were excited about him.
That was a very important fight.
Yes.
That was a Travis Brown wasn't it?
Didn't care.
Wow.
That's Kinda crazy.
Yeah,
that's w well,
I guess that's a personal thing,
right?
Your own personal motivation,
like the only person who could decide
what fights are up for and when fights or
not are you?
That's true.
Would you be,
would you be up for a rematch?
Like if they offered you
a rematch with Travis,
here's the difference.
If I fight Travis
now I'm going to want to fucking take his
head off because he disrespected me in
the ring after the match.
He did all this fucking
shit and it's like,
what did they do?
What did he fucking cut his throat?
He did all this stuff,
but don't you do that to
you do that all the time.
I have to do my thing.
He did it to mock me and I'm just like,
dude,
I've been nice to you and respectful to
you from day one and then you go ahead
and you go and you get a win on me.
Great.
This is your moment to say what you want
to say and what you want to do is to
try and fucking put me down after you win.
So you feel like by him doing this,
the thumb across the neck
thing and apparently he was
very dismissive of me and
interviews and all this shit and I'm like,
wow,
that's cool.
What do you disagree?
You're a post,
post,
all.
Everything is post.
Everything was post and I didn't find
out about this shit until way after the
fact.
I actually saw him backstage and
come up and shook his hand and said,
all right,
you know,
hey,
this was your night.
Me,
I don't have any reason
to be a fucking prick,
especially after I win.
But you know what a guy wins.
He feels like he's on top of the world.
You know what?
That's when you're going
to say some shit like that.
to act out and then,
ah,
fuck.
I'm just like,
all right,
cool.
If that's the way it's
going to be awesome.
If we rematch,
it's not going to be the same
dude you fought that night.
You have no idea.
You really don't get it.
You were,
you will get your ass handed
to you because now you made,
you gave me a reason to want to kick
your ass and what would be the difference
between the way you would
perform in this fight?
The way he performed,
the first fight I look for,
for one,
I would make him pay for all of the
big mistakes he makes all the time.
Like what?
Big mistakes.
He's constantly wiffen
throwing the biggest shots.
That kid has no stamina because he will
always go for the kill and everything he
does now,
if that makes him very
dangerous to a heavyweight,
especially because he's athletic
and he's got some power,
but that's why I've heard him took him
out because he's missing with all this
big shit and you're getting picked apart
and picked apart and picked apart and
hung on and hung on and
grabbed in separate and
picked apart and picked apart.
I mean,
why is Varun beating you on the feet?
Because he broke his hand
early in the first round two.
It's one of the reasons why.
Yeah,
well it's also because he's trying,
he's trying to swing for
the fences constantly.
Yeah.
That's why he's gassed and
every one of his big fights,
any fight that's got any
kind of distance to it,
he's gassed.
Why?
Because that's the type of fighter he is.
Does that make them a bad fighter?
Not necessarily.
I would say it doesn't.
It's just that's who he is.
He's a fucking wild man.
But that's also why I think he will
never be a UFC champion because there's a
finesse the he doesn't possess.
But don't you think that
that's something you can learn?
I mean,
he's a guy who is still sort
of evolving as a fighter.
He has him,
well,
he came into MMA fairly late.
It was a basketball player and what will,
I mean,
time will tell.
It's up to him really.
And I've got a personal thing with him.
Well,
but here I'm being objective and that is,
it's up to him.
If he wants to make those decisions,
if he wants to change his game,
if he wants to add
different aspects to it,
I mean all fighters are the true
or architects of their own design.
The coaches can help.
Edmund can,
can help him in one way and show him how
to strike under these concepts or maybe
show the same things that he's been
taught at Jackson's or someplace else but
said in a different way so that
it becomes more clear to him.
Um,
and I think Edmond is
a good striking coach.
I've seen him work with Rhonda.
I've seen him work with,
with some of the,
with the girls and uh,
before,
and I like what he has to teach.
I also don't believe that at Greg's that
there wasn't that there was any lack of
striking quality striking training or I,
I'm not going to say the Edmunds striking
training is going to be better than
whatever was it was Jackson's,
I'm going to say it's different.
I'm sure.
And I know it's good,
but I,
I'm pretty sure the Jacksons was good too.
And to make that change.
I mean only he knows specifically
why he decided to change camps.
But,
uh,
in my opinion it's not,
it's not about being here or there,
it's about what he does to,
to affect his game.
It's what,
what changes he decides
to make in his own head.
The way he approaches his training and
how he tries to take what he's learning
and apply it to what he does already
and apply it in different ways.
You know,
that's what it comes down to.
I think Edmonds given them
more individualized attention
and really focusing on
him as an athlete because he only
has a small stable of fighters maybe.
But uh,
in the end,
uh,
coaches lay the foundation,
they,
they point you in the right direction,
but athletes take that information
and they make the most of it.
If you,
how much time in a day can
you spend with that coach?
Only so much.
It's the time that you're
not spending with them.
That really makes a big difference.
How do you take what they gave you?
How are you working on that
when you're not in the gym?
How are you thinking about it?
How are you breaking down your
strengths and your weaknesses and,
and dealing with those?
How are you then coming back to the gym
with that knowledge and then training
the next day?
How are you setting your
mind for training that day?
You know,
you could have the worst day in the world,
but if your jab got better,
so what,
right.
It's a success.
Does it,
does it bug you that fine?
Like if you,
you know,
you look back in the fact that you didn't
get up for it and you had that result.
Yes,
of course it bugs me and it just,
as Travis has bugged from losing his
fight versus virgin because he had an
opportunity to fight for
the title after that,
I'm sure is the way he saw it.
And he lost his opportunity here.
He,
he may feel it was,
it was hand or you know,
when he got kicked in
the ribs or whatever.
It doesn't really matter what it was.
We lost.
We lost in these moments.
And as a fighter,
you always should.
That's,
that's something that I know when
I don't care if I lost or not,
that's when I should stop fighting.
I cared.
I cared that I lost,
I cared a lot more when I
got disrespected over it,
which I felt was completely unnecessary.
That's just suck.
That was like,
wow.
Wow.
Why?
Why did you have to do that?
So if you got you can't,
you have a hard time
getting up for Travis.
Why do you not have a hard
time getting up for Roy Nelson?
Because
for one,
uh,
I've had some time to,
to just do other stuff and get that fire
wanting to get back in the ring too.
I'm not looking at,
I'm looking at funding.
Roy's fighting Roy.
I'm not looking at fighting Roy as I'm
fighting Roy so that I can prove that I
can fight Joe Smith next so that I can
fight whoever and then get a title shot.
I'm not doing that.
I'm fighting Roy because I'm fighting Roy.
Me and Roy,
you're going to fight.
So you have a,
just a different mindset
than you had before.
The trout was for.
Absolutely.
And with Roy,
he's been around a very long time himself.
And so I've heard things here and there,
you know,
really one time it was on a
big rant online on Twitter
about people being ranked
over him and why,
why is that?
So he's,
he's arguing with all these
major journalists and then
he starts adding my name
into it.
Like literally putting my
handle and I'm just like,
why do you give a fuck about,
in my only response was,
you know,
finding wants to talk about how he
thinks he's better than me or whatever.
Who Cares?
My only response was who gives a shit?
What other people think about you?
Why are you even including me in this?
It doesn't matter.
Was there anything,
he's just trying to drum
up fight or whatever.
It doesn't matter.
It looks at list of potential opponents.
It feels he matches up well with you.
Throw your name into the mix.
Use Your,
you're at Shell Barnett,
you know at,
at the time,
I don't even think I was in the UFC
so it's not like we could have fought
anyways.
Well,
he probably knew you were
coming over from Strikeforce.
Right.
Who knows?
Everybody thought you
were coming over a few,
not work out the deal.
I mean,
you were always a top level guy,
right?
It's sub someone that a lot of different
fighters wanted to have as a potential.
You were,
hi,
my name,
you know,
high marquee.
It wasn't that long ago that anybody
ever started actually calling me out.
Like most of my career.
No one's ever said,
I want to fight that guy.
So what,
what do you attribute it to?
Oh,
I'm older.
I had a bad loss,
my last match.
You know,
maybe they think that they see it's,
uh,
it's more worthwhile to do that.
But even guys that had gotten wins over
me went through fucking hell to do it.
So there isn't,
yeah,
it doesn't make sense.
I don't blame them.
I mean,
I don't,
if I see a guy,
if I have a fighter and I can avoid
having a fight that's winnable,
but it's going to be fucking really tough.
Yeah.
I would try not to make
that fight happened.
I would try to get them
a fight where it may be,
uh,
a more dangerous fight,
but much more,
uh,
skews in the way of once you get going,
you can put them away,
but you got to watch out because
this guy can put you away.
Versus this guy's going to make you fight
and scratch and claw for every inch of
every second of this fucking match.
Whether he's winning and he's losing,
he'll just never fucking quit like that.
Yeah.
And that's you.
I will,
I break my hand and 23 seconds finding
Cormier and I still hit him with it.
You know what I mean?
And this is a type of fight that you
think would be that kind of dog fight.
You and Roy?
Yeah.
Well,
he's hard to put away.
He is hard to find.
I'm a finisher.
She's just crisis fight with Alistair
Overeem was crazy to watch him.
I didn't see it,
you know,
but I heard this kicks to the body,
saw walk,
saw walk.
You know,
Alistair was just laying into him.
He had kicked him,
he hit,
he kicked the shit out of his legs.
And Roy just keeps coming forward.
Alice just says it was
like the incredible hulk.
Like he just got angrier and angrier
and angrier and see his eyes get crazy.
He's a wild motherfucker Roy.
Yeah.
Hard to believe that he didn't even
start striking training till 2009.
That's when he started striking try.
That's not true.
That's what he said.
What?
He had to come food background too.
Oh,
did it really?
Yes.
I mean,
but what does it,
what does that
look?
He know he knew about
throwing a punch like this.
I saw him overhand.
Right.
A guy and knock them out.
And Costa Rica.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Costa Rica.
Yup.
You guys drunk.
What happened?
Well,
we were hired to go down there to
provide protection for something.
I'm just kidding.
What was it?
Oh dog dog when he was fighting.
Oh,
2007.
Eight dog was a fucking
interesting little scenario,
wasn't it?
It was.
I was,
I actually really liked watching it
because their production in terms of,
uh,
setting up each individual fight.
Oh,
by the way,
which is funny because my buddy Clint
doll did this thing called venom way back
in the day and it was
not legal in California.
So what they did is they
rented out a soundstage.
I was there.
You were at Vienna?
I was at venom.
So you remember them?
Yeah.
Tell us.
It explained the whole
soundstage and he hires John,
Sally and Steven Quadros
to be the announcers.
He's got all these fights set up that
they're all going to film in one or two
days and then they're going to
prepackage it to go to sell it elsewhere.
He set up roving cams,
hard Cam's,
he set up all this stuff.
He had all these people just show
up as extra to just stand around.
Which I guess you were
there hanging out too.
They ordered pizzas for
people to eat if the,
at one point,
and they call this thing a production,
you know,
in terms of a film,
it's a film.
It's a movie.
So he had these people fight,
pretending that it was like acting.
Yeah.
I mean while they were fighting for real.
But they just had it,
well,
it's acting sparring
as actors or something.
They tried some wacky
loophole and it worked.
And so did they get in trouble though?
I don't think so.
It's just that it never went anywhere.
To my understanding,
Sally was supposed to get it to the Fox
people and I don't know what happened
there.
It never,
it never took off either way.
One,
a lot of people got their start
there and nobody even knows it to.
Uh,
what they did is the way
they filmed all the fighters,
they had all of their bio's,
these backstories they had Mike,
uh,
what's his face?
Mike seal from New Mexico who was a bank
robber in Mexico and he got in trouble
for that and came Amy.
So there's all these
stories about these guys.
And so how Bodog got a hold.
They use the same format partially
because one of the duties it was pro
producing Bodog have venom from way back
in the day and basically just took the
whole concept of how they would
produce it and use it for Botox.
Would they would put on fights on
the beach and close to regrow loans,
hot chicks around best ring girls.
Just about everyone.
My God is that paper view.
I can't remember.
I remember watching on TV,
it was on TV,
so they shot it as a TV product.
They would shoot all these fights over
four days and then they would chop it up
and the TV episodes and uh,
it was,
it looked really fucking cool
because they just run out of money.
They basically,
the Ph,
there was a lot of people involved in
Bodog that were basically just robbing the
coffers while the king sleeps.
They were just running it dry thinking
it was just going to be a failure who
just get all you can while
you can and just fuck it over.
And they did.
They used to do those billboards,
Calvin,
I or presents Bodog so it'd be
handled dog fights like on a throne.
It'd be him with like a
beautiful suit on his face.
Like nobody's buying the
fights to look at you.
You didn't make any sense.
It was such a vanity.
It was,
yeah,
it was definitely retarded in that way.
But uh,
but I have really was down there.
He fought a Mario Renaldi knocked them
out with and ride out with an overhand
rule.
He always could punch.
I just don't think he was training it.
Well,
according to him,
I don't buy that list.
He also used to weigh like two 20,
two 15.
Anything.
Frank Mir and uh,
grappling contest.
Remember that?
Yeah.
What did it,
what happened was he from
near was all over him.
Like fucking white on rice,
got tired and then Roy
just outscored them.
But what happened?
Why did it,
what,
what did Roy do that made them gain all
that weight and keep it on while he's
getting in shape?
That's what I don't understand.
I don't think,
it's not what he did.
It's what he never stopped doing.
You know,
I don't,
I just don't know how you
could be in good enough shape.
We can go three hard five minute
rounds and not lose that gut.
I Dunno,
you had a fuel that God,
that God has got to be.
He said he's working on that thing there.
Maybe there's a little tape forms in
there and use an engine inside that just
keeps them going.
Well,
there's a lot of padding.
I'll tell you that c eight,
those fucking Alistair
Overeem potty kicks.
I don't even think that
pattern can make that big.
That's it.
That's just being strong and tough shit.
Yeah.
Well that'll be a good fight,
man.
I would like to see that fight.
I you still do.
I think it'll be entertaining
if it'll actually happen yet.
Uh,
I think it will,
but yeah,
we'll have to see once,
once we have paperwork
and we have wet ink,
ink,
ink.
What works.
All right,
we gotta get the fuck out of here.
Uh,
Josh l Barnett on Twitter.
Um,
anything else you want tell the fine
people about before we get the fuck up out
this bitch.
Check me out on axis and progresses.
No,
I am not good.
You couldn't do it the
way I wanted to do it.
So I said,
if that that's not fast,
not capable,
then I'm just not going to do it.
Let's just do it on your own.
Do it the way you want to
do a lot of fucking work.
Dude,
you should know.
Listen man,
this is all you need.
Get a phone,
start talking into it.
Talk Shit.
I bloated online called
the Josh Barnett podcasts.
Take it from there.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I did some good things on it,
but uh,
it wasn't,
there was a lot of stuff that,
that just wasn't allowing it to
it to really be what it could be.
All things in their own time,
my friend,
all things in their own time.
Josh l Bar Net,
motherfuckers watch him.
Metamorris it'll be May 9th,
May 9th May 9th really
interesting against Cyborg.
How do you say his last name?
But I've only seen it written.
I've never actually said it a brew.
I've heard it anyway.
He's in the amazing Jujitsu fighter.
It'd be a fantastic match.
Josh Barnett,
Ladies and gentlemen,
anything along.
And you got up for 20.
Vancouver just went on sale
today and secret show next week.
But Tom Segura,
Christina [inaudible] and Steve Agee and
a bunch of people at the comedy store.
And you've got something in San
Francisco and Sacramento coming up.
San Francisco,
Sacramento next month or
may all these tickets,
is it called sticky icky or purple?
Nurple it's called Sukkot.
Bitch,
we're going to get the punchline.
Me and Tony.
Oh,
and I am at the car theater at
Mandalay bay or at a the MGM,
uh,
rather.
Um,
uh,
is,
is that may,
when the fuck is that?
Yes,
it is.
It's a maybe 20 shit.
What,
what date is that?
A 22nd.
May 22nd Tom Segura May 22nd,
uh,
MGM,
the car theater with Thomson
[inaudible] and Tony Hinchcliffe Holla.
Alright,
my friends,
that's it for this week.
See you soon.
Bye.
Big Kiss.
Okay.